[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
you what's going on brown
talk to me what is popping i see y'all
out of here akw
hustling motivate sick slayer what's
going on
stitch what up wild night last night
sure do you know
oh squirrely dan what's going on brother
i see all you got to desperate
okay you got the coffee cup on deck
that's what's up anthony boy my guy
what's up audio's good thank you also
appreciate you brother
[Music]
mobile what's going on i see you early
death what's going on y'all
chillin sinister what's up wild night
what's going on
chillin you know what's that for seti
what's going
he was in the chat with me now you're in
the going bushes
guys get repaired what's going on so we
gonna
chill a lot of spicy topics today
a lot of stuff going on eagles fan 76 oh
man thank you brother my favorite
podcast
has been otto ah thank you it means a
lot to us it means a lot man
are you related to philly eagle there's
a lot of eagles fans we got
what's good oh man i like feeling we
representing we got a lot of philly and
we got a lot of dmv
and a lot of like europe and canada that
was like kind of outreaches
he feeling good he put the tweet out you
know what is it oh he connected back
like that
i just wanted to do his mic shake a
citizen said you feeling good about that
um
rocket launcher you want to talk to him
can you hear me now we can tell you a
little mic check there
what's going on
going on guys griggity what's up so yeah
we see on a bit
can go roll through any minute i was on
the phone so he'll push up right through
and that's all we'll be coming through
you already know so i'm gonna talk to
you
i caught that my bad akw it's always
your birthday's on tuesday i want to
give away something on the show next
week sunday oh i really appreciate it we
got you man whatever you want to do
whatever you want to do that's what's up
happy happy soon to be born day akw
evil fan you just got that philly yeah
philly show a lot of love man we
respect the ball respect the bulls out
there so we see y'all man
i'll talk a bit
[Music]
[Music]
became
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted
to flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i am well it's not important who
i
am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical
and yeah i be keeping these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
of people check my vocals all on twitter
but i'm anti-social love
[Music]
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again hear you hear you
man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social my city but i'm still by
[Music]
coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again here you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until the time to get this show started
so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being a cannibal
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with the gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's do that again
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to get
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it and
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
addict email email email welcome to the
in-laws podcast and the lords of
gaming.net
episode number 193 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
and today we've got xbox live gold
reversing course that's going to be fun
oh yeah
hitman 3 performance resident evil 8
and 10 acquisitions to discuss so we
gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the four horsemen of
gaming those original lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host with the comos my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of his own world and the heart of
the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty the first thing i want to
say
is you're looking at the proud owner of
an eyes of tomorrow
and i want to thank king and cognito
for carrying my wack ass when i died to
the
and they carried me to the victory i was
like yo keep shooting
i have more i had more storm um i went
back and watched it like right before i
died i got a whole clip of uh
of the the cloud strike on him yeah
and i was i was cloud striking the mess
out of it and i got i'm happy that i put
on that uh
fast sniper reload yeah because yeah it
yo
it really makes a huge difference oh oh
yeah
so so wait did did cog and king get this
weapon
yo you have it already i haven't
received the weapon but um
i'm gonna tell everybody right now today
after this show i'm raiding again
i got two other characters and i'm going
in and i'm trying to you know make it
happen i got two more shots at the title
and um i didn't yo the first part of the
raid right i was so mad
the first part of the raid we opened the
chest nothing popped up
and then everybody was like okay let's
move on moving at the hell you mean
let's move nothing popped out of there
you you know what's funny uh king when
um
because you know how like you see you
see the exotic before you pick it up
i didn't see it because it was behind a
legendary so i already had in my mind
i didn't get it yeah i'm walking up
there and
and i'm sitting there expecting nothing
and when i got it i like
i just flipped out like i literally
had an episode he would shout out to uh
daniel he said for those who do not see
he was like a child on christmas when he
got it
that pure joy so if you want to get the
uh
there we go okay because i i did private
the live stream
but um i will put the me getting that
oh you got your glorious woven recorded
oh how nice no no i'll put
i'll put the reaction on uh the iop for
members
in patreon no no no we got eagles fan 76
with the two dollar super chat team
godzilla chat end of discussion
yo i'm gonna tell you right now i gotta
watch that trailer i'm pretty sure that
they dropped the trailer already
oh yeah that's right it's today yeah
yeah you know i'm a huge
uh oh yeah and i love king kong but um
somebody got to get this work
so this is this is this is in that in
the line of movies with the the kong
skull island right yeah they've been
there
all right the whole world okay you know
they was building up to it and i'm i'm
you know cold we're supposed to get it
last year colby yeah yeah besides
popping bottles about either tomorrow
that's been it sir
yeah and plus you know i want to point
out you know let's do a little game pass
uh thing oh okay uh you know let's do
some game pass talk
introduced me to a game called monster
train i think that's what it's called is
that what it's called
uh i hate this man this man i i'm not
liking the energy he put out on me
because now i'm obsessed
i had every intention on playing
hitman 3 from beginning to end and
beating the game and reviewing it
but then king shows up to the side like
he's a master he's monster train
and i i haven't played it now i'm gonna
tell you i don't know that hit matthews
for you though man
because it's slow it's like a methodical
thing that's not your thing bro blazer
though i think right
no he hasn't touched it he's just said i
know he was gonna get him i knew he was
gonna get him when i downloaded it and i
was like oh but i told him it's another
game
that is monster sanctuary yes i said
when you finish that monster train
meet me over at the monster sanctuary
he looked like he told us about yo shout
out to your christmas oh yeah we lost
them
he battling somebody over there young
chris
raid right after this so don't disappear
bro
we got a eagles fan 76 again with two
dollar super chat kong going out like
connor last night sorry
good good transition oh we'll we'll be
talking
about what we'll be talking about and
of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity
and lord patreon of the iron bank my man
no picture today but we know why lord
sovereign
no doubt don't apologize for the lack of
camera uh it's probably
maybe like this next week as well just
giving you guys a little bit of fort
warning
uh yeah it's been a week i'm just leave
it at that it's just been a week it's
been a week so i'm glad to be here
yeah listen we're glad to have you here
we know you got a lot of stuff going on
i think you naked
oh my god it could be
[Music]
uh
commercial the world may never know man
at the end of the day like all for all
you know all he got a shirt on
i mean listen i mean 99.9 of the time
i'm in my drawers that's for sure
oh yeah that's a hundred percent our
female listeners
[Music]
nathan i cheated and i watched a good
bit of the
resident evil village demo so i didn't
get a chance to actually play it on my
team
yeah i mean it looks great i i i
playstation for spending good money on
the demo
i mean didn't they do it with the uh
with the first demo for seven as well
yeah
i believe so i feel like that's that's
good money spent though
yeah you know what it is because now the
narrative around people who not really
paying attention they think it's a
playstation exclusive
so it's it's smart on them and it worked
i guess we know it's going to play at a
lower resolution
shout out for going out there showing us
what it's going to look like
on the s oh my gosh so yeah
i i haven't gotten to play anything i
would have loved to play some hit man oh
bro i got you i got you like i said it's
been a week so
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues it demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
better than connor
[Laughter]
hold on real quick 108 dragons with the
10 super chat
do y'all see the chat it's not xbox
versus playstation today is
king kong versus godzilla day ps i'm
actually watching the trailer right now
as we speak
he's standing up godzilla is game pass
kong is
ps now this is wild
facts but um last night oh shout out to
lemon and his daughter going to college
the blessed thing especially in a
community
of uh you know the browns and the docs
we always champion
you know further in your education
beautiful giving back to the community
being in a positive
light so lemon i salute you for being a
great dad doing what you're doing
making sure that your baby get to
college baby i saw that and i was proud
so you know it's so funny how excited he
was and she was like yeah whatever like
you know what it is she don't know until
it's her turn to do it for her kids yeah
shout out to that man that man man i was
smiling for you brother that's that's
love
all right so okay so last night right we
in the raid and it just dawned on me
what the hell
happened with the connor fight now yep
before the fight
i was looking at him and i said man
connor looked off
and in my head i said it might be uh tko
or
choke out in the second round but old
boy is not known for choking dudes out
like that
right oh i said he's going to strike
with connor i said his worst
thing to do with congress would be
striking
right and connor was getting him with
the strikes
he got you running while i'm running one
run was his he was winning round two
yeah you know but he got counted by that
left hook
and and he noticed right off the rip
connor played it well
right you notice right off the rip he
not right
i think connor was weight drained i
don't think that's connor's weight
anymore
his leg was terrible like double leg
kicks roughed him up
people don't understand all that goes
into mma yeah
connor has been off for a year he's
older
he's older he's slower he needs all that
we
sparring now i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
laugh at a king that go down it's just
how
how this king gets up but covet
and uh the layoff hurt a lot more people
so those dudes that's on the undercards
that was working that was getting all
that work and stuff like that those not
those lesser known dudes
you know those dudes were in a better
position
i thought kind of had that fight until
he got counted and i think he would have
beat dude
but you know it is what it is um shout
out to oh boy that was talking spicy at
the end oh yeah
he's talking spicy but um connor's gonna
you know mix it up
yeah he was like yo um that's what
happened when you fight you make the
millions from floyd
you fire your team that made you the
champion and then you got some light
work back
up b team cause they wouldn't listen to
what you say i was like
i mean and connor said that he was like
you know you can't
you can't be inactive here you can't you
know take months off and come back and
think it's love like it's not it's not
that not everybody can do that and like
king said like
he's he's older he doesn't really belong
at that weight class
and now he needs to fight something
closer to his normal weight so he's not
cutting all this weight you know what it
is
he like shocking a little dude yeah i
mean he did it from the rip that's how
he got big by shacking a little dude
like
but you can't do that with the old body
now i'm gonna give it i want to give a
shout out to everybody that came out to
see me on dolph castle x yesterday
on a live unboxing
yeah i made it a thing and um as you can
see right now you see black bolt the
king
right over there with the screaming out
there you know um i'm not gonna do turn
to beat around on him right now
um and down at the bottom uh dr strange
is down there
but uh the live unboxing saturdays is
real fun
you know come out and if you haven't
seen premium unboxings come in have a
good time
watch us do our thing fridays you know
we do the actual show
but i like to thank that and for any
fraud that told me when i'm going to do
the one chip challenge that was done
last week
shows how much they watch
with what's going on call out a couple
of frauds but okay so what i'm playing
right now on game pass is two
like three which one which one like
three okay okay
all right so you know i'm a huge fan of
torchlight uh and
i'm gonna go with your recommendations
they end up costing me life
but you really like torch
so my son and i was playing last night
you know green mason and i was playing
last night it's a multiplayer as well
so it's an rpg
monster sanctuary then you can meet me
at torchlight 3.
but that's all i've been doing besides
raiding with cognito and not getting
eyes of tomorrow
yo so you want to get to jason funny
super chance i did
give me a second hold on hold on i think
it was all we got
we got dizzy with the five dollar super
jack kong slander will not be tolerated
on the lord's day
only one title for the king and he sure
wasn't the one getting face masks
meteor medium medium review 1 out of 27
jesus jesus
oh there we got 108 with 25 chad thanks
my brothers i almost hit up i stood
strong as best i could
i turned into 108 crying dragons later
though
still have butterflies very proud
beautiful thank you man that's beautiful
thank you beautiful tears of joy
brothers then we have squirrely dan with
the two dollar super chat
addicts out here scratching like tyrone
bigger
yeah that game fast with that with
yo so i'm just i'm this kong versus
godzilla thing right
obviously godzilla breeze fire didn't
yes yes guys they look at the little
baby arms though like
like my thing with that is like to me
kong would be
like way more mobile than godzilla would
be so
yeah i don't know i i feel i feel like i
feel like
like like logically this should go to
kong like every time
but like i mean i don't think
i don't know if kong can do enough
damage that's required to actually hurt
godzilla either
remember one thing when king gidera
in the beginning of godzilla was the
last godzilla movie and he ran at
godzilla
remember king either is over 900 tons
right godzilla stop that met that grab
boy he'll buy his throat
push it down let's go do that
cong kong is matured now they may they
have to have a mature
to get to you know godzilla's level and
it's going to be a nice fight
y'all saw the punch in the face and they
that's to get y'all riled up
when you burn the skin off your man
like who thinks it's going to be a draw
just for pasta like it's going to be a
draw
who who thinks they're going to fight
something bigger at the end but oh yeah
they're going to fight
they couldn't do the fake out right so
um i do i want to ask the chat put a 1
if you think kong's gonna win and put a
two if you think
godzilla's gonna win i'm curious you
know but yes a little man
this hype has been crazy i don't even
know what's going on shout out to david
carmen got a tremendous article he's
been getting the hype train rolling
you know what i'm saying with that so
salute man lord gave me that next yeah
that popped up on my timeline i thought
we had it already i was like we got it
man no one thinks kahn's gonna win
everybody wants some godzilla
dylan's the king man we already know who
swims away in the water
oh there you know what i wanted to give
you i want to see another
uh movie like uh freddie versus jason
justin versus freddy
yeah because i like those like i felt
like those are amusing and
they they had a really good point to
them no doubt yeah until they until
jason pulled them into the real world
and they had to work them over
that's nice with that dream stuff jason
was like what [ __ ]
shout out to 188 with the two dollar
super chat team king kong where you at
in the bushes
[Laughter]
damn the trees where you belong oh
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself
the shinobi lord cognito spreading that
realness in the ramen iop not telling
what you want to hear
what you need to hear so yo it's been a
lot of gaming this week man obviously
destiny shout out to addict forgetting
that
tomorrow i was very pissed with him but
i have to hold my my anger and my
jealousy i was so happy
yeah your joy was so really felt and my
hate
was reciprocated because what just made
it worse is i didn't think i had it
because i didn't see it
but i got it so happy right what's funny
is
is is forte said i had like the the
hallelujah hands i was like this yeah
oh my god i can't get it oh my god but
anyway silly funny because
at the same at first what's your
mccauley got it
right and here's oh yeah y'all gonna be
mad with me
because i was like yeah exactly and i
was like yo how you you already got the
j oh i was furious but
listen guys you know when when you're in
the room and you're raiding for
x amount of hours and you know the level
of frustration starts to reach a peak
um don't look for someone to be a
scapegoat and stop
acting tough on xbox live we are grown
men
you know that are have jobs have
children
and we all demand respect so you know
when you tell people oh it's on sight
when i see you
because you wasn't using divinity right
like that all you're doing is further
alienating yourself from the realm
so at some point in time you have to
realize that the problem is and
everybody else the problem is you
and you must own up to your stuff and
you must apologize to people because
if someone said something that you did
not like you tell send them a text
message we are all family
and you handle that behind the scenes
but you do not at no point in time when
we are alive
disrespect any man because every man
stands tall
so like show respect if you want respect
you show respect and that's how you get
respect
we're not doing wolf tickets over video
games yeah because
nobody nobody listen and i'm gonna tell
you that
nobody i'm not gonna allow nobody to
fight over no raid
so if you even think that it's on site
you're just sadly mistaking you just
especially at the age group involved
[Laughter]
let's just look around i said did he
just say it's on site man if you don't
get your your ben gay
movie the law but thank you for being
here oh you want to get that stuff
yeah we gotta stick to the two dollar
super chat to make matters worse i got
it on that run too
i'm gonna pay to rub it in
we didn't need your information either
man you could have kept that to yourself
actually you know what i got the eyes of
tomorrow so talk your talk like
you look good over here okay whatever
bro you're just village i'll see some
people in the old grounding game what's
going on philly eagle what up two eagle
fans i get confused eagle76 said philly
eagle
but anyway yo but anyways do it shout
out to that we did the raid we got that
going on
i want to shout out the last word we eat
bontes we have my man cloud
plays from the uk man you know what i'm
saying so that was lit yo check that out
fun show talking about what's going on
yo saw yo
jack is a like a dragon oh okay
bro it got me at first i'm gonna be real
the first chapter and a half i was like
it was dragging i felt like it was every
every part of this game is narrative
every part like narrative
you do something they want to talk about
it they do it it's a cinema like it is
the production value is high
but i just wasn't grabbing until
something happens and i was like yo
oh this is different you know what i'm
saying so yeah yeah when once it flipped
and i was like okay
this is fire you know i mean so you know
i am so addicted because what
the story is fire then the character
don't take himself seriously
oh yeah he's like the game be breaking
the fourth wall
and did it be wow funny yo it is
funny i don't want to spoil it too much
please stick it after chapter two
please stick it give it a shot man it is
one of their best job i am
completely addicted to this game shout
out to sega shout out to you know phil i
gotta get phil
dominus maximus aurelius spencer for
making it happen
you know what i'm saying because i know
i've been i've been off i've been off i
know i've been messing up his titles i
know i've i've been doing this
but um i've been doing that and then
yeah did they hit i got the hitman 3.
we'll talk about that i'll talk
only issue i want to say now before we
get in depth is
no bad no shout out fraud alert on the
um important hitmon 1 and hit man two
until you hit mantra
it's not working it is so many problems
to get this simple thing done
i own both games i'm only able to get
hit man one maps
you could tell it was something that was
like done at the last minute or
something like that
on them the reason why because it was
already in xbox
game pass so i don't know if it's there
for me already right
but then it's a new remastered one but
it's like
five different versions so this is the
thing now because what i had done in
anticipation was to make sure i
re-downloaded everything on hitman 1 and
2.
um so is it basically just
re-downloading
upgraded versions of that for three so
me downloading them previously doesn't
matter
i don't even truly understand because
again it's almost like a licensed thing
right because when they tell you you
don't own it it takes you to the
microsoft store right yeah so then i'm
like all right fam i
own it why is it not here it's telling
me i own it
right so that now hitman won it worked
and had to trade him at and
all those is upres all that is next-gen
optimization
but anyway long story short they just
got to work that i heard they're having
kinks with then they have like a website
they like yo
attach your io account to it so i went
in and i logged into hitman one i logged
into the hitman 2 make sure it was
attached to it
the correct account but he still did it
so i heard from what i heard the website
is having a lot of issues p
a lot of people are having my issue for
what i heard so i'm gonna give them time
to work
this is this is the one that i i think
has gotten the most traction
with the most people obviously because i
mean the start of the year that
it's i mean i think it's the most
polished and best one from what i've
heard oh brother we're going to get it
to i don't want us because we got to top
it but i'll talk about that later
and then yeah i did the uh resident evil
uh maiden demo
on ps5 oh you did that you turned your
ps5 on yeah
i'm afraid i i guess i turned my ps5
i'm surprised you turned it on because
you know it might blow up in your face
well when my space heater gets going i
already see what's good though
shout out to gdo in the chat shop to
philly as far as the um
watching the last word this week yeah it
was a fly episode thank you man song
we'll get some check
yeah um
so the narrative uh playstation has no
games is is over because they got a demo
oh no oh no let's do it that is another
conversation
so we have uh we have lucious augustus
with the five dollars to the chat
phil had to come down from the top floor
to yell at some people for xbox to
reverse his ex wildlife gold decision
within 24 hours of the announcement i i
don't know if phil had to come down
or if god had to come down and smack
phil i don't know how that went
we got it we're going to talk about it
we got cedric age of the twenty dollars
with that
in the trailer you can see a glimpse of
mechagodzilla really
really i didn't see that but i'll look
closely then we have seen tomlin with
the five pound super chat
there will be a definitive winner that
have they have said and it's kong making
godzilla's woman or godzilla making
congresswoman
that's my prediction oh
[Laughter]
very bold prediction sir one of the
other is going to win that's like one or
the other
okay that's it we're caught up aye no
doubt no doubt christopher hart
i don't normally read your stuff but um
let me tell you this being that you
don't have an xbox you wouldn't know
what they got but i could tell you
that your playstation has no games you
have a dlc that was three hours without
the cutscenes
and i finished it frozen
so you're playing the background demo
that came free with the game and it gave
you another devil to have fun with so
have fun with your demos
we got introducing you you had it you're
at it you got to hit christopher
with the bye
anyway that has been it for me game wise
oh let's do this poll man let's get into
it last week poll results are in and the
people have spoken
to the question with the recent reveal
of a new bethesda-led indiana jones game
what do you think will be the outcome
regarding platform
exclusivity all right this is by far the
closest poll in the history of iop polls
the winner of the four-way iop poll at
36.3 i had to throw the point on it
of the vote was indiana jones will
be a true exclusive group
coming in that second at 35.4
percent of the vote was no exclusivity
this game would be multiplied and game
pass group
coming in that thorough still kind of
close to 25 percent of the vote was xbox
will have a one year timed exclusivity
and last place at only two percent of
the vote was i don't care just throw old
harrison ford in indiana jones in the
bushes
so yeah this was this was this was close
man king you are the victor
once again you've been on fire with
these these people seem to agree with
you all the time
so what do you have to say for yourself
sir
it's inevitable you can run from it
you can look away you can hide from it
it will happen
all this y'all thinking that microsoft
is in the
in the realm of playing nice you already
see what they're about
if they hear the words in the street
they listening to the concrete the air
is on the floor
they got cold air right now because it's
cold outside 20 degrees outside
phil is frosted over because he's
listening to you cry
so i'ma tell you he hear xbox dudes and
it don't take nothing but a snap
to make you go away
yo your copy is going to be one of those
things that popped up on digital foundry
20 years later
this is with the police station
diversion yo you stupid i
i'm gonna tell you though by the end of
last week's combo i was kind of turned
i was cuz yeah because and it's
the funny thing is it's just i wasn't
paying attention to my own argument
because at the end of the day no it's
funny because like if
if my argument is that when they sat
down to talk acquisition
they had to open up the books and
microsoft knew this then in knowing this
from the beginning
it makes sense that they're going to pay
7.5 billion for for
for xenomax right whatever's coming
along with it they're going to try their
darndest
to get to be exclusive if the if the
play
is we're strengthening game pass with
everything that we
have then yeah the play would be we're
going to try to make indiana jones
exclusive
so it makes sense it absolutely doesn't
make sense
dark side
[Laughter]
we like you over
no i just wanted to talk about the poll
oh yeah okay get it
when it comes to i honestly think that
you know
it's going to be an exclusive i mean who
knows how it goes to it but
i just got one thing to say to
playstation people if it is exclusive
bye
[Music]
80 right let's get two more super chats
together
smitty smith with the five dollar super
chat christopher are out here like yo
check out my demo son the book come back
please listen to my demo
[Music]
there we have k megan with the five
dollar super
ftw let me shout out the legendary kate
mega from grg
had an amazing podcast with this brother
yo shout out to grg please subscribe to
the channel man grg podcast
absolute great time we was talking
classic games he
he hit me he boxed me in king yeah he's
like yo you only got to pick
three of your boats of all time so when
it came that's what i was like yo i
should know me number one the ninja
cognito you already know
you know what i'm saying number two halo
get the tvs the whole projects together
you don't say it change the game i
wanted to say
yup king though i wanted to say destiny
so bad
but i was like we started talking at
least vomiting or archangel we vibing on
a 10 minute joint
you know what i'm saying so it was super
lit man i gotta say destiny for y'all
has to be closed no that's these no
right there five yeah
yeah top five somebody gotta box you in
for top three did he yeah
with the gun in my head and said you
could only pick three i got it the
impact of
tekken was so powerful
one from the standpoint was in my
opinion it was the first
our fighting game that was kind of
arcade perfect
when we got it on system 11. and we had
extras with the cinemas
and all these oh my god namco band
that's when the playstation was in their
back right then second two changed the
game
awesome right animations counters all
out
that was man transformative then they
was doing the cottage they
really brought martial arts to the
forefront king had capoeira i had my
taekwondo
you had king with the wrestling that you
knew all the 10 hits and
kicks all was beast so i'll get you in
the rolling cato it was over oh my god
the rolling death cradle exactly man so
i had to
say like when when when i put the guns
in my house like tech it was so tekken
hat
king remember tekken had cats pulling up
to the spot
solo brothers bro we gonna go to the
bowling alley arcade right now
we're gonna remember i had to get him up
out of there
like five seconds that's my greatest
movie the thing is this
right y'all would be surprised in my top
three if i had to pick a top three
yeah and my top three consist of
the most influential games of
of my group right it's going to be halo
facts definitely that's going to be top
top
top one game period if i had to pick one
game in my team
on an island it would be halo the whole
series
the next one is that wrestling um
yeah it would be those three games
because i'm gonna tell you something
i've
never cause i wasn't about that
wrestling until i got my man because i
was always picking
undertaking i would get my yo and then
it turns
the the worm turned uh the worm turned i
was like i'm all late
i see what y'all love and and then
tekken
individualities facts had they
when brian came through think about it
with brian i just thought about it
yeah soft got his name's sake from
tekken from
shout out it's funny like i i was
calling myself
the sovereign from like they didn't like
that name because i came out
and i was like all right we all got to
find a dominant name
and i came up with that and i'm like all
right i'm gonna run with this
and then to see the way i played with
king was very like my
my goal was to get you in the rolling
death cradle that's the
some way shape or form gets you in that
and then finish [ __ ]
disrespectful that he rolling around
with you and you seeing your life ball
deplete and it's just so disrespectful
you
and then and then when i transitioned to
brian fury oh
yeah yeah it was it was like so shout
out to kate yeah
when king was talking about wrestling i
thought he was gonna go way back with
the pro wrestling the next
we got all that man i mean we did that
we did and i love that
star man
you remember you remember the the pro
wrestling for the for the master system
shout out to the bad sister for being
messy with the big hands but i gotta
give eddie us that one and he has had
that one yeah they definitely had that i
remember
i remember when i first saw wrestle war
for the genesis
and i was like oh my god oh my god this
looks so real
and then when the game came out but
graphically it was the best thing we
ever saw
at the top
everybody would go to that nes though
and and they'd start using that star man
and flipping off the top ropes all the
time because he had the moves you know
was it what was the other great puma or
something like that yeah
you guys remember saturday night slam
master oh yes
wrestling games i remember it the
japanese name because i bought the m4
and it was called
muscle bomber the spot the body
tremendous tremendous wrestling games
with wrestlers man we could do a
wrestling podcast all day
he said we could do pokemon
let me let me get this uh superstar we
got kingdom with the five dollar super
chat i think microsoft heard one of
king's rants on why he pays for
slash trust live over psn and they tried
it
they definitely was going with my game
plan somebody read my
dude we all caught up yeah we're good
we're good i saw that it's on you man
we're going to transition
right into the main event here
you know what i'm saying so what's going
on with uh did something happen with
xbox live gold this week
did anything happen
the worm is turned on this one
i picked this topic and i thought i was
just gonna be a topic whatever we're
gonna
you know talk a little bit about it but
uh the internet thought otherwise
all right so um on friday out of nowhere
uh the xbox announced an increase to the
yearly subscription of xbox live from 60
uh for a full year to 120 for a full
year for new
uh for incoming xbox live members
and the internet had a lot to say about
that and none of it was good
um not more than 14 to 15 hours later
after a lot of vitriol online
they came out and admitted that they
made a mistake
changed course on that in addition to
announcing things that i
you know have been in the works for a
while but they have we weren't
necessarily ready to announce but
they are finally removing the pay wall
for free to play games on xbox live
so uh they took a big l and turned it
into a w
um and the question is why did they even
do that
what happened there what was that whole
course of events that happened and why
did
it happen so uh let's talk about it
let's talk about it man let's get
let's get for a lot of fun man i seen
you lit on on twitter for a bit so i
want to get your feedback and that whole
from the initial
like so i was saying announcement to the
reversal
we exactly sir well when i initially
heard about it
um i was in a chat with uh colt
and some other people and they were
pretty livid and they were like why
would they do something like this
and you know i immediately got upset and
you know this doesn't necessarily affect
me
personally it doesn't affect a lot of
people out there that
are already on gold and they have that
rollover every year they get they keep
getting paid you know they pay for it
automatically
right it's grandfathered in yeah but
i can't help it and and people may say
that you know i'm white knighting here
and there or whatever
but i always speak up for the consumer
in situations like this
because i am a consumer and i wouldn't
want to be done wrong if i am new to a
certain product
i don't want to feel like i'm being
shafted and
this indeed would shaft a lot of new
people it would shaft those people that
say maybe they lapse in a payment and
and they don't pay uh for one month and
they come back and then all of a sudden
they're hit with that hundred twenty
dollars you know
for a year uh it's crazy
that that doubling of price and so
immediately i took to twitter and and i
added xbox added phil spencer
oh he brought the smoke and not because
i was mad at
phil spencer per se but i need to
because i'm not i don't know who decided
this was good for xbox but i had to
point fingers at somebody and say
hey phil look you're the head of xbox
you need to do something about this
basically i told him and i was very
polite about it but i was i was
firm i said you need to roll this back
and then you need to take down that pay
wall
for the free to play games i said that's
some goodwill faith right there that's
what you need to do
and that was one of my that that was
like my first post i put out there about
this
and it's just funny that they added that
paywall thing in after
but i just knew that that was one of the
ways that they could
save some faith so to speak but
seriously
with this situation being the way it is
and the way it was carried out
it makes me wonder who called this fact
why did they call this
and especially within you know the time
period we're in this pandemic this whole
situation where a lot of people
are still waiting on unemployment checks
um it's just crazy about no video games
if they worry about how to eat
oh here we go
you should not entertain yourself
for somebody that's choosing video games
over food king and nobody's
i don't think anybody's really doing
that but my sentiments
is that there is people out here that um
maybe they're going through some stuff
because of this and and this is the
gaming is an outlet for them to just you
know
get out of this whole real world you
know mess that we're in you know
they can go into some other world and
and virtually
we have a console for them that don't
charge you to be online
king you can't give me a don matrix you
can't give me that
because i hate when people say oh if you
can't afford it
get out you know when they up the price
on things because
we know what these people are making we
see the financial reports
and i'm not having it how do you stay
rich
i mean like this this question is how do
you stay rich
right you don't give your money away you
hold your money and you add more money
to the money so
you know we looking at and that's how
you stay and that's how you stay
uh i'll just say an expletive because
but that's how you stay an a-hole pretty
much
this is true and microsoft has been
building
a foundation lately on goodwill
they've been building up this reputation
hey
you know what has where has being nice
really got them it's got
some media attention saying hey
microsoft is doing some good here
has it transformed the narrative to be a
number one because in order to transform
in order to transform the narrative you
have to have
great compelling games coming out for
your system
exactly and until they but until they
come
you have to just sit back there at
number two
number three and and you just need to do
whatever it is you can
to be that nice guy because price on the
one the weakest basically that you got
to make people turn to the better
platform
yeah but see you cannot force a bit
that's not good business to force
fantastic business that's terrible
business because you're not going to
turn those that don't like game pass
to go get game pass
or they get in see this is the best part
about this whole thing was
when it went down i laughed i laughed so
hard
i i i had a cackle in my throat that was
like oh my god because it turned
it turned into get in on a lay down
mm-hmm
they put the gun out right so a lot of
the tcl
dudes would say there you go oh
playstation now you know it's still 60
bucks then play over there unfortunately
king i gotta tell you
most of the guys on xbox are tcl dudes
and that's the problem okay you cannot
look at your fan base
the majority of your user base is still
on gold
and you can't look at those guys they
don't want it over you can't sleep
right you know what you have to entice
them to switch over
and again that goes with the games and
eventually
and i put out a post on that too i said
as soon as you get the compelling games
there
people will switch you do not force
people to games
this was basically extortion
okay this is a strong arm tactic this is
what this is getting on a lady
you know you got the other dudes over
there that's not giving you anything
compelling
and they they have they treat you
terribly and they're winning
so when microsoft is treating you nice
and they're getting third-hand deals
yo i'm sick and tired of it let's be
ruthless let's just
they're not in a position for them for
the narrative you know right now i'm
playing devil's out yeah i know what
you're doing here in the world
debate and it's it's a good thing
because people need to hear both sides
right because they can see how reminded
is absolutely tragic
how ridiculous king's side sounds
because you cannot force people
into something they do not want it
that's business 101. you cannot do that
this was downright extortionate man
technically you can yeah i mean this
happened now to try
now to the point about about diverting
people to game pass would this was an
obvious ploy to do
remove from the argument the people that
are playing only free to play games and
now finally they go
they're going to be able to have their
box without having to pay to use
so remove them from the argument but
let's talk about the gamer
that plays one or two other games and
that's it they play cod
they play maybe sports games mad and
they don't play anything else
and they're saying to you hey i don't
want game pass regardless i don't care
how good it is don't roll
anything into anything i just want the
most basic thing to get me online
um what about that argument see that
that's the argument that
that that's another number don't
necessarily know what it is but i think
it's pretty high it's
it's high because a lot of people out
there are either you know
getting an xbox or a playstation just to
play cod
or or fortnite or free to play game you
know or
if they do play cod they only want gold
you know they don't want they have no
need for game pass a lot of
gamers out there to be honest a lot of
gamers might buy two or three games a
year and that's
it you're fine check this out
what if what if this was the grand
scheme what if this was the grand scheme
they weren't really trending at all
right
so it was it was a downturn and i tell
you put out bad news on a friday
and um they said yo how about this how
about we flip the world upside down
double the price check this out this is
my conspiracy
we haven't stepped on the rake in a
while let's do this
check this out and everybody goes i'm
going to let them dig in right
microsoft i can't believe microsoft
again
microsoft oh my god and people is
putting out videos shout out to all the
people that put out videos ranting and
rape i was laughing
the whole way through i watched
everybody's video it was so much fun
yeah i can't believe microsoft did this
they doubled up
and then boom we switched it and then we
removed the paywall
what if this was a whole play to tell
you oh my god
free to play
you know what i like about this part it
doesn't matter what you think about it
what happened is they didn't change the
price
and free to play is free to play
and they walk away smelling like roses
they fight
no no no i disagree king because i think
i think this black eye
is is still upon i think that there's
still remnants of that black guy there
that's just playstation i think i think
no because because here's the thing
because you have to be
you have to be suspicious all the time
of these companies
and this and this thing it's like okay
now i know there's somebody within the
brand he wanted this to happen
who is this guy and how how does he have
this much pull
to try to do this in the first place
what if it was the whole team
you got to keep one eye open this one
man i i you know i
that's the thing though i don't think it
was the whole team because i heard
things
but i'm not going to say well i heard
things and some people are really pissed
at the end of the day though i think
regardless of whose fault it is how this
happened
right like all roads lead to phil hmm
and if you want to blame him you also
got to tell you when he did the spin out
move and he told his
his receiver go long he threw that the
hail mary to the end zone
and with the dance give him the praise
to fraternity
saying no no no no but that he's gotten
that my question here is this
if where where do you sit in a boat
right now in the board
where do you whiteboard this and it's a
good idea
exactly and it's a good idea to co-sign
to do it this way
right everybody everybody's in agreement
that the path is game pass how do we
filter people to
game pass them into the box exactly but
even then
yo even yo dude even when you when you
take cattle to slaughter right you do it
in a humane way you do it so they don't
know what's happening
oh my god have you ever seen the video
they know what's going to go down yeah
they don't know
they're walking down that little they're
walking down that little tunnel then
they get the ball boom is over that's it
i'll tell you this they showed us the
gun that they were gonna shoot us with
listen you guys better get your ducks in
a row all right because this is just a
foreshadowing for what is truly to come
i mean okay so i joked around with fines
on it giving you the uh the side of the
corporate dude
the corporate the snake who doesn't get
snake doesn't care about your wallet i
don't care about your covet
right so that dude didn't care i'm
i'm i'm gonna honestly say this right
and just to everybody that's on this
panel that pretty much feel the same way
that it was really like the skull of me
a villainy
um be afraid
because get your ducks in a row right
and start looking at it because it
didn't affect anybody that's on here who
has game pass ultimate
who has uh xbox live and we're godfather
didn't cause we our credit cards will
keep it going
and shout out to rand for uh allowing me
to know that part right because i
thought it just switched
and then everybody was affected by it
you guys got to be fearful that these
guys want
more yeah from you know it's coming
exactly
it's coming game pass 20 to 25 at some
point
yeah but they should just remove live
all
and they're trying to figure out how to
do it
this is the thing right to me even if
you all right you increase the price of
game past five more dollars whatever the
case may be
and just even if you are charging me for
live in in that breakdown of money that
that goes into x
you know game pass ultimate if you are
charging me for lives like you said
eliminate it so i'm not even talking
about it in in my mind you've eliminated
live
even if you're still charging me for it
let me let me jump into something
because it's really touch i was going to
save it for when i go but it's really
touching about what y'all talking about
right now
shout out to z huge he had a great
thread on this
and basically what he said here's the
problem he said as far as the whole
thing he said xbox knows they have two
issues right now
it's a lack of skill not just on console
but beyond console and he said number
two
not everyone millions of people have
confirmed have not converted
from gold to game pass ultimately he
said the company has been exploring
multiple ways to solve the issue
removing gold doesn't guarantee those
users sign up to game pass
making gold part of a lower game pass
tier
de-incentivizes them to upgrade to game
pass ultimate
he says so what was the solution he said
initially he said well
somebody in one room said double the
cost of xbox live over a 12-month period
why the assumption that most users will
see the value in upgrading
to a game pass ultimate sub that's
getting more even if some do not shift
the assumption is they stay at gold or
at the higher cost
which increases their sub revenue anyway
he said so basically he said the simple
fact is everyone everything microsoft
done has done recently resolved around
trying to get as many people
to sign up to game pass as they can the
company needs as many
core console players are possible on the
service when it gets to acquire
new users long-term cloud all that stuff
final point
the reversal shows that xbox is indeed
responsive to criticism
of how achievement goes it does not want
to have a repeat of the xbox one launch
debacle
but it should be noted that xbox like
this is what king is saying that's what
stop saying
xbox will continue to find a solution
to increase the revenue per user on
console
100 that's a hundred dollars but this is
this is the problem right
you have to try to and i'm not saying
it's easy you have to try to figure out
a way
to to do it where nobody feels slighted
and that's that's not an easy thing to
do right well how about this how about
this sub
how about had they come out and said
look these are the grandiose changes
we were planning on making for gold
before you try to up the price
you got to entice people with you know
say hey we got this coming
so this is why we're doing this you know
and they're not doing that
and that's why with game pass if they do
up the price which eventually
they will we've all been saying this for
now but when they do
we understand it's because they have
bigger and better games that are being
implemented
it makes sense right but for gold those
games are trash
let's be honest and and
and you're not going to get anything
better in gold it's just not going to
happen because everything is going to
game pass it's worth a damn you know so
let me get i don't know because
i'm dying man i talk briefly and i'm
dying to get addict on the attic man
with the whole thing when it went down
you put the video out you know what i'm
saying after when they reversed
but give me your whole mindset from the
beginning right now
to where is that now what what so
let me get a play-by-play all right so i
was
let's go i i was uh i woke up and i was
you know probably up for about like 45
minutes it's a good day then i get on
twitter
and i see that and i'm just like one of
the things i don't understand is
is like the amount that was raised it
wasn't like 10
20 like
let's say something right now they
didn't technically raise the price they
started
giving you discounts on gaining multiple
amounts of ones
but the problem is is people been used
to that 10 15 years you you buy a whole
year up front you get 50
off they stop that so they didn't
technically raise the price but they
took something
that the consumers used to i know a lot
of people
i know more people that pay the ten
dollars a month and actually buy them
all
all the whole year up front for sixty
dollars right yeah so you know
do i think that this was an issue yes
i think that um but do i think this is
something that would like destroy their
bottom line
not really uh i'm glad that they changed
it because because at the end of the day
i can all
i don't care about they money i care
about me as a consumer and
raising that made me feel like
they'll they'll try something else
that's a huge thing it's like
oh you know because us coming together
and first off i want to give a shout out
to everyone there because like we
couldn't have done that in any
individual shop
we might joke about the playstation
fanboys the xbox fanboys the pc fanboys
regardless what your motive was to
attack this narrative
i'm glad you did regardless the game has
came out bro
unified you doing this could have
potentially
delayed game pass going up a year
oh can we can we just point out to all
the frauds that tried to defend this
and argue with me on twitter on this
yeah you're welcome
no and and i like to say this i want all
you playstation dudes to look at this
and see that y'all should fight for
those dlc's that they're giving me
your voice shall be heard
with these slimy practices microsoft
understands that it was slimy and they
washed their hands of it
but not today
all right the kid what a lot of people
bringing up
incidences uh such as the the 70
price tag trying to like make that a
sony problem i don't think that's a sony
problem that's
that's more of an industry problem but
sony is partaking in that
yeah and some of us tried to fight
against that
some of us put that out there yeah but
sony doesn't listen to you
microsoft unfortunately and that that's
that's what i want to point out it's
like look like
we need to do this more like the gamers
should be running this
industry not the other one no we do not
let the inmates from the asylum
oh my god shout out to the gm
houston texas they should be making
games
that we buy to keep the industry going
not making no
they can force feed us to keep the
industry it's it's a point proven that
gamers really don't know what they want
so we will not be listening to that
never no
no you don't have to stop that i'm gonna
have to have but cause you know listen
uh
get off your high horse look i i get you
got the 10k tv i don't know
look at that hey hey christopher hart
says sony listens more than xbox does
you're right
they listened to all you frauds that
said yeah we'll gladly pay 80
for greatness they don't listen to you
because you thought you was getting a
game that was on playstation five only
and they
lied to you oh you being generations you
you've lied you have no generations you
got demons
that's another thing look look at the
end of the day
regardless if it's stone regard if it's
microsoft garbage nintendo
like we need we need to have we need to
put them on trial man like
that's why i put up look sound like rudy
julian yeah
but it's just like look i want this i
want this energy for more stuff like
this i want this energy for the seventy
dollar titles i want this guy
for me too pain online in general it's
like look like
stop how much more can microsoft do for
you
no one's talking about like no no listen
champion what you're doing they're
saying hey you said 70
you know what they said okay nobody yeah
i get you know you guys know when you go
up but what addict is saying
is gamers on all platforms you know what
i'm saying because
each one of them have some practice that
we all
like that's it like i'm waiting i want
this energy for nintendo voice chat for
switching they don't
listen i'm talking energy for messaging
you
know
i know that's what i just like it's a
beautiful thing what happened
do you think this might be just like a
geographic thing like you know because
i can't i have to admit like the
nintendo's the sony's
they do have like like a barrier between
them and their fans that you can't
really get this type of reaction i know
let me talk man keep talking and keep
interrupting
like you say i interrupt you you've
interrupted time and get your passion
like like i i honestly feel like if this
kind of scenario will happen with
nintendo happened with sony
that it never gets fixed i really do
like you look at the voice chat thing
you know how many people attacked them
over the voice chat thing
that never got fixed how many people was
a 70
price tag that never got fixed right
remember when sony was legitly
like they were removing your your your
uh what is that
psn account if you did a chargeback on
your playstation
no one no one said nothing like not even
media
cloud saves behind a paywall cloud
safewise
never got fixed like like where is this
energy and people watching
it's just because this is an xbox thing
no it's i want the whole industry
what's right for us praise the lord
you know what you do that's the funny
thing you know what i was going to say
you know what you do because a lot of
people argue this as soon as this
happens
they're like get a pc
when we tried to fight they told us to
get a pc
because it's free over there remember
keep giving gabe newell money we're
doing that
vote with your dollar yeah don't buy
nintendo don't
buy something just buy a microphone
i don't even think necessarily
you you don't even have to like do any
kind of monetary thing that's the best
way to get them
but i've noticed throughout the years
there's not enough people to come
together that hit them in the wall
it's just not it's not most the time
it's not possible just
like but you know what's free giving
your opinion
on social medias in a criticism way
that's not disrespectful
that gets their attention way before
money will and that's because
companies companies fear the pr night
the pr backlash because they know it's
going to lead to less sales
and that's why the voice on the social
media is going to get their attention
before half of the people decide to
stand up like
how many people
you're not gonna get free reign to talk
so we we all gonna get into this we all
can mix it up you can jump in on my
stuff
all the time but the king don't listen
to you the one on top of the mountain
can't hear you the peasants down at the
bottom microsoft is the peasant down at
the bottom fighting up
right you know let's be honest let's go
let's call it spade a spade but
they can't have this nightmare sony
don't kid
you don't care because people are still
patron their situation
because of the fact that they on top
right so
let me ask you a question though let me
ask you because you said the key
he said you said they they don't listen
to you no well when people backlash over
the spider-man thing with the cross says
what happened king
what that's the key
defense there have been situations with
the cross saved games when they were not
transparent
about that the game spider-man like
miles morales was coming to ps4
like they made a big statement that they
was completely different from
microsoft's philosophy
and then we come to find out right and
again
the the the anger the anguish that we're
seeing now
in my opinion didn't match right yeah
and then with 70
games as a whole as the industry i'm not
seeing this anger
yeah yesterday the energy match for the
most part you had the people that
that you know were saying what they were
doing was right but the energy was there
right like when it comes to the the 70
titles the spider-man
the spider-man thing it was a big name
the energy was there so they got that
took care of that something small
that sony's like look this is small keep
them off our back do it but the energy
wasn't there for the 70
thing that's why i'm saying if the
energy and everyone comes together and
the energy's
they're going to bend but i agree but
the problem is
in my opinion that people have their
loyalty to their platform and they don't
hold them in that same level i don't
think it's just
that i don't think it's just that it's
also based on
a lot of people's assumption that just
because we haven't had a price hike
with games in so long that it's time
because
they always like to add in inflation
right yeah
and and here's where inflation just
doesn't add up
when you look at their financial reports
and you look at things like you have to
factor in
that we now have things like micro
transactions
which make more for these companies than
any one of their games
right yep and and this was not a thing
back
you know years ago uh but with the last
price hike that we got
i remember the online thing that ubisoft
used to do yeah
no i get what i did with you on the
seminar
i'm gonna be on i'm still mad that no
one fought with me
for the nintendo voice chat and the
messaging that's where i'm at
that's nintendo being attended right and
that's thank you
you see what they said they beat to
their own drum
they you know they make quality first
party games
it's that's just how they do they're so
wacky that's they're so wacky
no mistake though it didn't make it
worse to make it worse they had the
feature on the wii u
and regressed that's why and no one's
going
i've even drive i've even done it myself
king that is the issue that statement
that you said that's just the nintendo
being nintendo
the nintendo fans came together and
bitched about it and they don't come
along with everyone else
all gamers should come together not just
nintendo
see the thing is is a lot of nintendo
guys say that's okay
right that's why i'm saying because
we're not getting the energy from the
ignorance
everyone else is not getting fixed the
reason why they say it's okay and the
reason why they say that it's nintendo
being nintendo because they know they're
not changing them
right that's the whole thing so instead
of attacking the argument and fighting
the argument and pushing the argument
you know your voice is not being heard
and
that's a sad part right there where you
got to accept it
right and and this this shot this shines
a huge light on the industry as a whole
this whole thing you know we yeah we did
come together we did shout out to
you doubling up that is the difference
that we had from this scenario that we
have from last scenarios
is when it comes to something usually
the core
never holds them accountable and that's
what always hurts them but when this
this price rise on goals the majority
xbox people
had their pitchforks they weren't having
that you know listen it was another time
when sony
reverse streamed that remember when
they did the drm remember that on the
playstation 4 when it came out and you
had that hour
long or wait before that press
conference and then they were packaged
listen our voices will be heard
if they fear the bottom line right
microsoft feared the bottom line
so much that hell no
we got to take this out and what's the
thing that they'd be calling for the
most
the free to play games let them have
that because we don't really need off
when they were in those meetings they're
like yo man we we jack we
messed up like we got to do something
else like we can't just come out be like
yo we ain't doing that you know we we
understand we messed up
they're like we can't just come out
there with that statement we gotta have
something
on top of it that makes it better and
this is the thing i think
they're the only ones that had to do
this like if
you we ascribe the same scenario to sony
i don't think i don't think that they
don't do it the same way
because of that that lack of fear the
bottom line i think with microsoft they
they also took along but to king's point
when you are the king and you are the
market leader
sometimes you're less receptive to
listen to the problem
i want to piggyback off that being the
market leader
because here's the thing if if people
would have stood up
against the 70 games back when you know
uh
who was it that started doing that
activision
you've got 2k 2k and then and then sony
did it
when sony did it being the market leader
of you know the console space
and basically you know the gaming
freaking
you know console gods uh of this
generation
they when they did it and and nobody
really put up a stink about it except
for a select few of us
right it was easily to take that over
and just run with it
and now it's set a precedence that
it's inevitable other companies even
xbox
eventually will go to that price point
it's gonna happen and i even asked you
you guys remember when
aaron greenberg was on rds yeah i
remember you were young i jammed him up
because he said i love you he said the
words i think he was dancing around that
question
oh no he he was and and i wasn't having
it
uh i respect the guy um but at the same
time
you know i know his job i know what he's
trying to do he's to sell xboxes and
game pass
and i'm not about that life i'm a
consumer so
i'm gonna ask the hard questions and as
soon as i asked that question about
hey are you guys going to go to 70 games
you know he was dancing around
and stuff and he goes he said the words
i i just don't want to hear from people
well what does it matter when they're
all in game pass
that's the problem because i said that
we're eventually going to get 70
titles exactly exactly
a lot of people do not want game pass a
lot of people buy one or two games a
year and they don't want to pay
70 dollars for them and i think that's
the biggest issue that we have
is i do feel like microsoft does like to
use game pass as
uh um you know a scapegoat for a lot of
different scenarios and it's and it's a
great value but
that's why a lot of people uh there are
a lot of people that have access to that
kind of internet connection you need to
even use game pass to the way you'd have
to yeah to buy to download the game
you know if if everything goes up to 70
i can't you know there's not a whole lot
we can do at this point because half the
industry is doing it now
so but it's just like you know rollback
yeah
there ain't no rollback i mean that's it
and then i'll jump in after you yeah
we gotta we got a massive each other we
got a bunch of them
yeah the last one okay so we got nuke
nukem with the five dollar super chat
oh no no way we have it before that we
have new we have xbox gamers
we have philly eagle hold on like we
know we got hustle and motivate
mm-hmm fight our super chat i'll be here
king
how about that free pay wall removal sir
i said xbox should have done this when i
was like a guest on the show keep up the
great work iop thank you
yeah that's a fact absolutely then we
got philly eagle with the five dollar
super chat xbox live is free
keep beating this horse it's free if
you're paying for it that's a you
problem sorry not sorry
where is it free i don't i mean there's
a part of it that's free right
technically but not to play online if
you play online you need to pay
am i wrong in that if there's no xbox
live silver anymore isn't it
yeah i think silver's done yeah okay all
right so we have uh smitty smith with
the five dollars in the chat at least
the xbox gamer spoke up but the fake
five star generals
and playstation land just sit there like
abby and just take it
got him iop book of x oh
[ __ ] then we had so much so much
scripture being written
now we have new nukem with a five
dollars
i'm pissed and still a bit pissed
microsoft may have removed the dongs
oh wow but didn't put away the vaseline
jesus my goodness you know what that
means right there i'll be back
[Music]
[Laughter]
that the telogen free
that's right keep me warm i'll be back
dan the bear cunningham with the five
dollars in the chat
the issue isn't just that they raised
the price they did it suddenly and gold
hasn't been improved to justify doubling
the price
uh now the thing is gold
this is something they didn't just plan
this is this is something they said oh
let's raise the price they've been
working on this for a minute
so but again yes they didn't tell you
where where the value was right
you caught up no hell no sorry we got jd
gamer with ten dollars
nintendo says we're doing what we want
and what we want
won't be traditional facts yep yeah
shout out shout out set out to switch
into
one of the front lines don't have
another jd gamer
so we got more yeah we got we got more
we got them here
sony says we're doing what we want and
what and we're the market leader deal
with us uh microsoft says it's all for
the gamer well let's hope it continues
out and we got one away dragons to the
power of that
this shows the gamers have power we need
as a community to unite on real issues
and we will get results or don't make
the purchase
bosses will convert
can i say this i say this gamers are
real quick to jump on twitter and talk
about what they don't like
but at the end of the day when it comes
to the dollar
when it comes to the almighty
and that's the problem um we got
scrolling down two thousand chat
the amount of gamers have also been
inflating in numbers that is true
we got jd gamer again with the five
dollars of a chat question for the panel
uh what if the proposed price increase
was to finance another acquisition from
xbox's own coffers instead of microsoft
that's cap i don't believe that see the
thing is jd
is you don't raise stuff like that for
like short-term purchases you raise
stuff like that
like to me like if they wanted to go
about and buy a company they would just
go out and buy a company yeah
i don't feel like they need to like like
low-key do a gofundme
yeah exactly that's what it means like
yeah yeah we we need to raise funds for
this particular acquisition
do we have you know a trillion in the
bank
they said we're going to double up on
gold so we can buy a soul
let me say something real quick that
they came out uh jd and said something
like
you know we're go we want to fund more
games with games with gold or something
that they
something besides just raising it it
would
i think they would have got a little bit
less backlash yeah
it still would have been horrible you
got to explain what you're doing right
you can't do well it's like i said they
didn't technically double but you can't
take away the stuff that
people use to buy your services and then
have no reason why you did it and don't
have
any reason that that makes more value to
the service
of why you did it isn't that the whole
standard like
like when you go to the gym you buy a
gym membership you can pay monthly
but if you pay the whole year you get
like like at least 100 or 200
off right and that's the incentive to
pay for the year
damn incentive is you know it's like
look like we want your mo
we want your commitment for the whole
year oh thanks
what's wrong no no he's not god was
talking
about his life oh now cause
that's the incentive it's like look we
want your commitment the whole
year so what we're gonna do is we're
going to give you a discount so you're
in our ecosystem
you're buying games using other
subscription services there's literally
zero reason why they would do this
exactly
no we're not caught up not caught up
hold up we got one away dragon two
dollars we chat nintendo voice chat i
have your back [ __ ] all day
augustus no nintendo wouldn't listen no
matter what pokemon fans freaked out
about the multiple thing and they never
got that
they never fixed that facts where by
nintendo dudes
honestly i honestly think it might be a
cultural thing man like i really do
because
i don't know i don't know like that sony
and nintendo don't really take that kind
of criticism they're both japanese
companies like
it's like i have to look at that it's
position
i don't think it's position when you're
in the when you're in the
because they do change think about it
this way right when microsoft was the
boss
what happened you had the don exactly go
get another system
go get we got a console for you you
don't like online get over there
was the boss with the police station
yeah
japanese companies they're they're
they're heads strong they they're very
proud of what they do and i feel like
when they make
when they make changes they stick to
them regardless the backlash i think
it's the culture
i think the cultural part about it is
the fact that they don't
have that communication right i think
that part
the social media yeah exactly is the
fact that they don't they don't care
about necessarily having that connection
with their community
that's a good point no that's a good
point i put out i think that's a
cultural style
and that's always sort of been the case
you know we don't have a say
we just buy it well they don't because
again you're making a good point solved
because
i see a lot of people who are against
xbox fans to say
i don't understand how they praising
them and giving this pat in the back
they got this weird connection
to their these corporate exactly because
the difference is
microsoft actually even winning or
losing yeah
executives are on the front line
interacting with their communities see
i'm saying to be honest
and the difference is let's be honest no
fanboy talk
you know i'm saying sony and nintendo
are harder to get a hold of
their their leadership they they're not
public facing
like that you know what i'm saying i we
go to these shows you know
sometimes that bites them in the book
though being on social media
sometimes it does and then other times
it works
but in general i would prefer it that
way no matter what like rain or shine
whether they when it does bite them in
the rear i'd rather they be that way
to be honest with you man no matter what
they do people aren't going to be happy
they're always going to use it against
them i remember
i remember with the the mess up with
that event where they said they were
going to have a lot of
what is it the third gameplay yeah
regardless whatever it was that event
that they said they highlighted gameplay
for the series
aaron greenberg said he's like he came
out he they they
i like when companies own this stuff
they messed up and they like
that's on us facts i prefer transparency
he said look he's like
we promoted it wrong i apologize we're
definitely gonna take it uh you know
we're gonna consider that we're gonna do
better
people were literally saying aaron
should have said nothing what you mean
aaron should have said nothing
let me ask you guys something how often
do you see
uh and i'm not gonna go with uh anybody
on social media but
media in general how often do you see
media really attack sony when they do
something that's
possibly anti-consumer the hardest i've
seen it i i did say it one time we were
at
e3 fortnight is at its height
and so we did not want to do involve
themselves initially with the
cross play yeah and i've
never seen that that was the mo i've
seen like shot
greg miller i've seen a lot of the big
issues they definitely got off
they said sony this is wrong you got it
that was one time
right and my caveat is i'll let me
finish
is that it took fortnight which was like
biggest juggernaut to get them to
finally come to the table
but check this out what happened since
then there was nothing there was a
change in the guard
that's true they went back to they went
back into a hole
and there are no front-facing execs
anymore at
playstation really even you mentioned
greg miller you mentioned greg miller
right
miller still has pretty decent access to
sony generally like they'll get consoles
they'll talk to devs when's the last
time he had
an exec on there that's a good point
like they don't even have that point
though
yeah and to piggyback off what you said
about they have
a new they got you know a new executive
and like jim ryan okay jim ryan took
over essentially and
and he told one of the biggest lies ever
jim loose lips ryan
anyway he told one of the biggest lies
in the industry when he
you know did the whole hashtag
generations thing that they believe in
generations
and that they weren't looking to put any
ps5 games on the ps4
and all this stuff and it was all
fantastic and roses for the playstation
community
but not only did the playstation
community really didn't give any
real backlash when when he faltered on
this
uh but the media didn't either in fact
the media wrote
let me
dc uh he says also that's not true
addict
reggie was all in the streets and
remember i i always mispronounced his
name
let's start the show with please
understand i never said other companies
don't take ownership they have i mean i
remember at playstation took ownership
over the
the way they wrote out the the uh
pre-orders i never i was just giving you
an incident that microsoft
had on not fair and reggie reggie's a
special case because
reggie had more autonomy
as head of nintendo america and reggie
could still for me
exactly exactly i don't think doug
bowser has that same leeway
i think i think bulk of things that
the bulk of decisions are are coming
from nintendo japan
and i think there's less argument
there's less of an argument than there
used to be with reggie i think reggie
reggie had his own ideas about stuff he
wasn't for the bs
let's listen they told reggie we going
this way
reggie was like i'm out all right that's
it sign me out of here
he made a podcast and him and phil is
over there talking oh my god
oh yeah we got a bunch of money
excuse me lucious augustus 108 dragons
no we got lucious augustus
yeah five dollar super chat no nintendo
wouldn't listen no matter what pokemon
fan no that's right i did read that
picture
correct yeah what correct pixel pixel
listen i'm supporting you thank you i
appreciate that
this difference is when xbox doesn't it
does something the entire industry goes
at them but when sony nintendo does it
fans bow down and media plays along
and you know what they say too this is
what this is that this is why i can't
stand
nintendo fans of sony fans you know they
built up such a good uh
credibility with all the stuff that
they've done in the past with their
games
shut up just because they give you cake
on your birthday yeah
i think the actual answer is that we've
been beaten into submission by them
and the argument that we said is that oh
this just
this is what how they do things this is
how they do
sony being sony so it's messed up but
it's true
jd gamer ten dollars we said the only
way sony is going to change anything
isn't if
their customers say so but if the top
tier devs say look sony this isn't
working
all are epic then sony will be bowing
down i'll cross play and save
just don't buy these stuff so i don't i
don't know but see
i don't know that their first party devs
are ever gonna come out and say
something
yeah so it would take again it would
take another game like a fortnight
right to be able to move that needle for
them
um and that's it i don't think
internally they're like on the same page
and they're not gonna
i don't see that strike happening
internally with sony first party devs
you know complaining about their their
policies in that way i just don't see it
it makes me wonder how clued in these uh
these execs these head of xbox and head
of uh playstation
are really clued into certain things
because
because you know you have this whole
situation to happen with xbox
and you know uh how how clued in was
phil spencer to this
because of what he's been saying uh and
and and then you got to think of
you know that whole hashtag generations
with jim blueslips ryan
uh with that whole thing because when he
was talking he was so adamant against
putting those playstation 5 games on the
playstation 4.
so was he really clued in that these
games were coming to playstation
but then fonz this is the thing though i
think he was clued in because then
later on he has a he has an interview
where he says
i don't see why people have a problem
with this he's like
he says that so it's like all right okay
so then are are
are you just announcing the fact yeah
or you're the or you're acknowledging
that you're the guy in front that has to
take
has to take the brunt of this beef like
you could so because when
when when god of war ragnarok comes out
on the playstation 4 because i'm pretty
sure
it will and when it does will there be
any backlash
no i mean you'll be complaining right
now because it's dlc
so they still fight like oh god it's a
full game the devs told you
the same way with miles morales it's a
full game it's a full dlc that you paid
for
and you're going to get a full deal with
you know
we use assets and stuff like that but
they're so complicit with what's going
down because they feel that they're with
the winning teams
right quiet and take stuff if they
feel like they're winning and they're
part of a winner they they
raise the noise when they feel that
these guys are losing
and i'm part of this team but they're
losing they need to change stuff they
need to do something different
microsoft needs to be quiet be like sony
win
be like sony well you know every company
is different
you know what i do love and what i am
championing this
this weekend in a matter of hours
yo yeah in a i've never never seen that
ever never seen that in a matter of
hours because they they set it as a
team the microsoft team
said we're switching this over and in a
matter of
hours that you know what's crazy
greenberg came out
and said non-cipher that's not
real and also free to play is here to
stay
all day so somebody
knows how bad social media can paint you
and if microsoft and and and xbox
understands that social
media can make or break you in this day
and age they're learning
and they're learning because craig face
i'm telling you
craig i think craig face did more
into pushing awareness and microsoft's
heads
than anything else i think craig we're
still
having residue of crap they don't want
residue of crap
this is this is crazy residue i get my
balls off
get
the living flame five dollar super chat
good morning lords friday was creeping
four days to the medium a true next-gen
experience because the ninth gen didn't
start with the ps3 game
oh here we go and this is this is what
another thing that bothers me about them
stepping on the rake for no reason right
now right
because with microsoft it always turns
into a snowball effect narrative right
let's say the medium comes out and it's
a 70.
that gets rolled into this right and
it's just like it's
because it's what happens and then oh my
god they're trying to do that
i'm just like fodder i just i get i get
mad when they step on the rig for no
reason
and we got loaded pixels at the final
super chat good morning brother what's
up michael
what's up bro everyone happy about the
price staying the same but microsoft
would definitely make up that revenue
keep up with the great work thank you
real quick there you go i dropped some
codes in the chat it's on uh
it's on xbox you guys have been you guys
have been really good here today man you
know we got
we got 430 people definitely that like
button if you guys are enjoying it yeah
this is a good conversation
and they're following that check cause
attic is dropping uh
now we got spartan ghost 17 with the two
pound super chat how much mario did
bowser's parents play
[Laughter]
um i think we're caught up hold on a
second let me see
this is a good one this is good shout
out to fox bring the heat king is funny
um look friday's news man shout out to
grg i was on there when it when it broke
and i was just like man what what we
call it
solve snatching snap snatching defeat
from the jaws of it
i'm just like wow like this was
unnecessary so my whole thing is this
you know i get the hustle from a
business standpoint we know what has to
happen
we know that they want everyone on game
pass ultimate we know that you know what
i'm saying
and they're looking at gold right and
they're saying okay what can we do
the problem is it's like attic said it's
like okay if you're gonna double
first of all you don't mention the
yearly part in the thing in the
description right you don't even it's
not
it's it's only one dollar it's only
three dollars if you do three
like they're just talking about the
short-term pricing
of gold right to fool you it's acting
like it's it's only one dollar if you
want to stay you know you new guys
that's it
but conveniently the 12-year option is
gone
yeah i hear you now and then it's
doubled so my thing is
if you're going to double it which is
still outrageous when your competitor is
not doing that
right your competitor's staying in 61 so
my thing is like foreign said
you've got to show what's this added
value as to why this is increasing
right you're clearly it ain't games with
gold because that has been decreasing in
value
right so what is the incentive you
you've not even explained it so of
course you're gonna get lashed
of course you're gonna get killed you
know what i'm saying and at the end of
the day it was beautiful to see people
step up because at the end of the day
let's be real this really didn't affect
og's
right ogs were still in pocket because
they were going to be grandfathered in
right but as far as the new cats as far
as like
you know um you know new box a new
person who picks up xbox live whatever
that's gonna affect them to me it's two
things i got out of it the good
right first gamers came through y'all
gamers came through it was united front
xbox fans were not with it i've seen the
biggest in the community say
nah they're saying it this is not it you
know what i'm saying so shout out to
everybody who came to
the cave because a lot of people say you
know xbox fans you know they don't ever
challenge oh no this was not that
you know i'm saying this was not that so
that was that the quest second question
i got is again to what you were saying
fonts is like
the boardroom versus reading the room
right who in the boardroom
thought this was a goal completely tone
deaf right
who who who thought but here's the key
thing that people are not
missing out too if you notice when the
news went out by
the xbox live gold team i don't even
know there was a gold team
or xbox why did you see that song that
the audience said
written by the xbox live gold team
i didn't know that existed but you know
he's neither here nor there maybe they
do and cox is not educated fight
right here's my problem i mean that
problem his was interested
if you notice when the news dropped not
one xbox exec tweeted it
filled in tweet yoda increase aaron
didn't tweet
major nelson did tweet so to me again i
could be reaching
but i look at that because every major
announcement the whole
it's a move it's a unified front yo this
is what we're doing
game pass ultimate doom boom right it's
a unified front
why is it that they did not tweet but
they
only tweeted once the correction was
made and then you saw
apology hey yo we messed up today gamers
this was wrong
to me again i'm just looking from the
outside in
this to me screams that i don't know i'm
not going to say it's a leadership issue
i'm going to say it's a boardroom issue
because clearly someone in the ballroom
thought this was a goal
and clearly others did not and were
willing to champion
once they saw the negative reaction and
then fired back
so that to me is very interesting the
fact that
it's like you said the fact that phil
spencer aaron greenberg major nelson
like not
one of them retweeted that so it showed
that it's like they knew the backlash
was going to be so bad
right if they're like we're not even
going to get ourselves in there right so
because i think i'm not going to never
i'm not going to be
ignorant to say they didn't know of it
because clearly
if you're failing you're that t you know
what's happening right
but it it almost is again just looking
from the outside
it almost feels like a silent protest
because why aren't you
champion this move if you truly want to
up
bring gold and this is what you need to
do why are you not doing that but you
only doing
when you don't say it when it was fixed
and then you're really kind of clear
yeah it's kind of clear to me because
because it doesn't
go with what these key people have been
preaching about
for months and even years and and and
and that's the thing like all that good
will they've been doing
was essentially erased within minutes of
that going live
exactly and it's crazy man and that's
why i say there's still a lingering
black eye there
with xbox even though that they they
reverse this
you got to still wonder as gamers got to
stay vigilant and keep one eye open
because something else is coming oh
something's coming they i mean they're
gonna dress it up a lot better
for sure but it's clear because this is
like equivalent to someone coming
punch you in the face and then coming
back later like might be
[Laughter]
it's like it's like they better come to
me with like a coupon to like
gamestop or something like you better
not just be one of those they just
punched me in the face and be like dude
what did you expect i punched you
yeah they gave you that they lifted the
pay well that was
genius that was jesus because it's one
thing to reverse
course but then there's another thing to
say okay you know what whoever was in
that team that said okay what else
do we need to do that we haven't done
and throw that extra incentive on
to kind of ease the pain of what they
attempted to do
you know initially so it was interesting
but it was man shout out to the gamers
shout out to the gamers man because
again
i was so proud to see everybody like nah
that the biggest the smallest everybody
was like nope
that ain't it and there were some dudes
that were super fanboys for xbox that
you know i don't even talk to and i saw
some of their tweets i'm like wow
and the last league oh yeah that was
crazy the last point i'll say is i do
the reason why and i see a lot of
narrative of
you shouldn't praise them right because
they did the reverse right you shouldn't
say that
this is the only thing i'll say and and
king said it best and fawn said
again i've been we've been watching
we've been gaming for a long time right
i've never seen a reversal in
such a magnitude not only was it done
in such quickness but then reverted and
then
given the add-on on top of it and the
complete mia culpa like we messed up
again no one's saying that we're not
justifying the initial wrong and the
action
we're just saying that it's rare you
never see
that level of transformative change
to get back in the good graces of
someone that i've never seen
so that's exactly why i think them i
went online and i thanked phil spencer
at xbox
right you know even aaron greenberg i
said thank you to the team
for reversing this because you did what
was right it's only fair that you
praise them when they do good and then
go at them when they don't
i mean that's the way you should be as a
concern right facts facts
no and that was good the last point is
that you know bad news always drop on a
friday
that's that's just business one-on-one
bad news you always drop it on a friday
you try to let it marinate you know what
i'm saying and at the end of the day
i'm just happy that they were cognizant
enough
to say okay now this is this ain't it
and we got to do
extra to get back right like farrah said
the bruises will still be there
but at the end of the day at least that
was a good thing by the gaming community
i felt you know what i'm saying but it's
good to see the chats that everybody
else got anything else to say before we
move on
we got dc's nerd talk with the five
dollar super chat what's up guys good
show y'all even though y'all bleed green
ah here we go again i got green on today
oh man i bleed i bleed rgb
keep up the great dialogue
then we have spartan ghost with the five
pound super chat sounds like it may be
john favreau versus kathleen kennedy
situation
is maximum shadow getting too big for
some people mm-hmm
okay anything else i think
by the way i bleed cyan there you go
what's the mixture of
red green and red i like that it's like
actually it's actually white depending
on what what
shade of red green and blue it's it'll
just come up white
what else we got anybody else i think
we're good i know that's all
oh one more spartan ghost two pounds of
chat i met maximus
maximus i know doubt you already don't
look bad crazy couple of days man that's
this was
this is interesting fun so i will say
i've never seen anything like it
and like i said was just an interesting
result but we got to move
on king's topic is up but he has stepped
away so i will take over on that um
yeah man so it looks like a hit man
three you know what i'm saying it
is out you know what speak to the lords
who have played it but i think
king was coming from a standpoint of um
performance
and um you want obviously digital
foundry i believe they did their uh
their whole
uh spew in comparison in reference to
okay
he kicks me back he just resetting okay
no doubt he's resetting his headphones
so i'm just holding down for him
but um yeah man so pretty much hitman 3
they've come out they've uh talked about
the comparisons
you know everything kind of moving at 60
frames per second and pretty much on all
platforms
now the playstation 4 i mean five i
believe it's uh
1800 p whereas the xbox series x is a
full 4k however
there is a segment i believe it's funny
i gotta throw this in this map
in the bushes so i don't know if you saw
this in the bushes there's a section
where the xbox in the bushes cannot
in this one particular segment maintain
60 frames where he's where he's creeping
around the bushes yeah
he's in the bush he's going to have it i
thought that was hilarious
vintage iop but um yeah but for the most
part outside of the bush's
secrets oh it's it's remains 68 at 4k so
i believe king wanted to talk about this
one if that's if you played it and then
i believe his
comment was um in reference to if he
if you guys think the sdks the tools
remember
are improving for that we will now maybe
trend towards seeing series x versions
be superior so far i'm gonna let you set
it
off what you think about this whole
hitman three situation and did you play
oh uh first shout out to the guy who
tried to make that fake video where he
was uh
looking like it was dipping down to the
40s and stuff and like
you could clearly see on the screen that
it wasn't dipping down but with john
lennon
with a hammer on that guy he said uh
that video is wrong sir
there was definitely a fraud alert on
that video for sure yeah and
you know i i don't understand uh
i'm not a big tech guy so i i don't know
the ins and outs of it
um dealer he's a tech guy and he talks
to me about it
and he was telling me that yes this does
have something to do with the
tools maturing the people they're
finally getting some of this stuff in
their hands and these devs
and you're going to see this stuff get
even better as time progresses
uh it's not just dealer gaming or you
know
your favorite youtubers or you or the
ones you love to hate on
on on youtube that are saying this stuff
this is also coming from a lot of
experts out there right uh like digital
foundry
you know that are saying yes the tools
are maturing and
you know it's it's one of those things
where it's a great looking game
uh i don't know why it dips down and i
asked dealer about that too i was like
why does it dip down in the flowers for
some reason
because that's got to be some sort of
bug right he he
he thinks they'll work that out and
they'll patch that and that'll be
cleared up
but we are starting to see a little bit
of a gap there
between you know playstation 5 xbox uh
series x
um and shout out to the series s that's
even looking pretty damn good you know
for for what it is
damn i i didn't what i did want the 1400
i mean the the
1400p only because the ps4 pro
had the unlock frame rate and um the
four cases i know obviously
i said i can't do 4k i was home before
the fourth 1440p on that that's just me
i'm always i'm always looking out for a
little man but continue yeah and as
spartan ghost said
it maybe it was too many particles on
screen at one time and dealer had said
something to that but he was like you
know the gpu and cpu are more than
capable
of running that area at 60 frames
there's no reason it should have dipped
like that but anyway
that's just you know one person's
perspective um
for me i don't know too much about the
tech side but for
i haven't played the game at all uh i'm
not a big fan of the series i
i think it's too stiff for me but uh i
wish his animations were a little more
yeah it's just a little too stiff i love
the game but
they are cool games for stealth games i
mean uh but the only stealth game for me
will will always be uh man it just
slipped my mind um
splinter cell winter cell those are the
only ones i really liked you know
the thing is is hitman is not your
average stealth game
yeah it's uh the whole idea of the game
but
the game isn't built on stealth it's
built on
you know planning your opponent it's
it's more than just stealth
still it's a component but it's not the
end-all be-all
it's it's stealth but out in the open so
it's not really hiding behind things
necessarily
it's about you know blending in it's
about blending in yeah yeah like they
did
disguise we'll get it but um all right
no doubt for us uh lord addict sir
your your feelings on this whole
performance the plus
the game i know i think you you got it
you've been copping you've been blazing
you know what i'm saying so
just your feelings on that as well too
can you hear me yeah yeah i got you
yeah it's it's a good game i enjoy it
it's definitely a lot more redefined
than
you know previous ones but one of the
things that i really enjoy
about it is just like how open the game
is yeah and you know i gotta say it
though
like the fact that even though that it's
one section i don't think it's relevant
once again this isn't just one game like
like how many games in the playstation
ran more consistently better
it's like you can't have the strongest
console and keep getting destroyed by
every multi-player game well they got
the resolution though right now they got
the resolution
but i care more about performance than
resolution that's just me
but it's just like if if it would be
different it was just this one game
but it's just like it feels like
playstations have more consistent games
than
an xbox and they have the stronger
hardware like you gotta wait for the
tools
but and i get it but that's not my
that's not my problem
like it's just like you promoted this
fact the way you did not the other way
around
they're going to come to usa look so 90
percent is 4k 60
versus the bush's part yeah so so quick
question like yeah
what is where the dips here
particular is i'm actually watching it
on video right now
one section the whole game from
understanding 4k 60 but when you get to
this one section where the bushes appear
the frame rate go into the butcher's at
about 50 or whatever whatever yeah so
that's the joke so again to what fonz is
saying shout out to dylan cause i think
daley did mention this
it does give the appearance that it is a
glitch but
outside of that one section 4k 60
throughout and
the thing is is digital fantasies
highlighting this section so people
don't think the whole game runs like
this
absolutely right shout out to that
that's about facts shout out to digital
to letting devs know when there are any
type of anomalies or anything like that
and i honestly do feel like you know the
game
see when it comes to me i came from the
xbox one s
right so everything is is gold
it don't matter what i'm doing
everything's going right but and i don't
really
i don't i don't even have digital
founders to subscribe because i don't
really care about their content but
but as far as like power wise and this
is the strongest system and this eats
beat monsters for breakfast like slogans
like that
and then you you look at something like
digital foundry it's like oh but the
playstation running better the
playstation running that better the
playstation running this better
sure it's it's it's controlled variables
it's not the whole game
certain sections of the game but it's
still certain sections of the game it's
still running a a
you know a game better than a system
that is is
supposed to be the superior right i get
you but i know where you're going
i know you're going and it's like i said
it would be different if it was just one
game
it's not just one game right they they
keep happening to re like didn't
von holla same thing you know they
microsoft
yeah but but at the end of the day it's
just like people so it doesn't matter if
they fix it
people people's first impressions that's
good you know i
saw the game good and i love the game
but it's like digital foundry puts a
video out there people are just going to
they're never going to go back and look
they're going to look at what was there
at the time
because in the gaming industry it's
really fast
it's not slow it's fast from here hitman
is
next week no one's gonna be talking
about hitman they're gonna talk about
whatever's coming out next week or the
weekend that's true
i'll tell you i'm surprised you like
this game
i'm proud of that he's getting his
stealth and methodical on
they said listen i saw i saw a mooch i
saw bg talk about
this is to this is too slow i am not
about this and it's like i said
i beat the methodical game so i beat dxx
mankind divided and
a human revolution without killing one
person i beat dishonor without killing
anyone
like i i love these type of games
enough soft man yeah as much of a hitman
fan as i am i have not had a chance to
play any of this stuff so i i can't
really speak to it but in terms of the
yeah i mean again this
power of conversation man i think it's
just getting old man at this point like
why why know when when serious actually
loses
no no it's just no no no it's you know
what it is they're both
out now at the end of the day as long as
they both
start running stuff great like i i will
have something to say if this
power delta is
yeah like at the end of the day i don't
care because i'm still getting a really
good quality
game yeah like it's like i do got to
point out just like look
the you know this isn't gonna look good
but you know the game looks amazing
regardless what platform you played on
but it is
funny like in terms of like a podcasting
standpoint it's like
this game was supposed to run better on
everything yeah that it was described
the way so if that power delta really
starts to show itself
absolutely i have stuff to say about it
but right now especially these games
that are still sort of crosstan or
whatever like
you know uh i'm if it's running great
looking beautiful like what i do know
is that they were talking about the
death specifically we're speaking to the
fact that
um they're happy that the xbox does have
built-in hardware ray tracing so they're
working on that
to bring that to the to the to the
console version
soon so yeah i definitely want to see
that um
am i the only one that's not really
hyped for ray tracing i mean it looks
good don't get me wrong it looks
fantastic
and it definitely looks next-gen but i'd
rather have that performance
well this is the thing at we have to we
have to go through the groin pains to
get there right because at the end of
the day
it is a more efficient way to do things
it's just that we're not at the point
yet
where the power of the machines won't
take a hit because
of the ray tracing so i mean we're
living through
the the first rung of it right right and
that
ten years it'll be ubiquitous and the
power
drain that that we're seeing now isn't
necessarily gonna be the case but we
have to live through it right
but i do think in the long term it is
the best way to go about doing lighting
i think it it'll make any game from the
smallest game to the largest game look
much better it is you know it's just a
thing we got to live through i think
mm-hmm on the chat real quick okay go
for it the
sip army i don't even know what kind of
name that is but that's that's
this is no no no no i got cause he
called me he's oh
don't care then just shut it and move on
and just don't go well with that
and the other thing look there's a
difference between not caring you're not
letting your voice heard
i don't care but i'm still going to
point out that it's still happening
i still played this game did you play
hitman decent army
look at the end of the day i'm still
going to point out stuff that
i find a little funny but i'm not gonna
just not act like it didn't happen is
that what you want me to do you want me
to be complacent you want me to be
to act like everything's you know what's
what i'm looking for yeah
nothing bad i'm still gonna bring it up
that's not what we're here for that's
for sure uh let me get the super chat
real quick
roughness roughness my man
people for the streets on the streets be
out here
roughly let's go i hit man 3 on my
series s
great game looks gorgeous can't wait for
thursday the medium
yes yes sir get up high for the beat i
want to see what's up yeah 30 frames
yeah
i knew that i was going to
have you do that and tried to play these
games at 30 frames it's hard now
i know it actually like i think i
mentioned this a couple of weeks ago
once you're playing everything at 60
even something that's locked at 30
feels janky it's weird it is bro
okay so i'm looking for a game to play
lately and i'm like you know what
everybody's talking about greed fall
it's very bioware-esque and i'm like
that's my jam you know so i download it
and i start playing that james get the
hammer get the hand oh dude
the the stuttering the the feel of that
stutter at 30 frames
is just terrible no when people are
spamming like that yeah get their hands
out just get them just get them out of
here that's all we do man but off with
his head
off with his head it's just tough for me
to play games at 30 frames now
it really is that gets you yeah yeah
it's it's a it's crazy thank you
but i mean again i i want to see
speaking on the medium real quick like
yeah i i just want to see because the
thing is
that's what i i think i talked about
this last week i'm worried about
performance overall because
they never fixed blair witch on console
like blair wish on console is still on i
i downloaded it to the series x i'm like
oh this should be okay now
hell no hell wonder if it's because of
small team i don't know the resource
situation and that's the thing so i you
know
my hope is that they the medium comes
out and it's fine in terms of from a
technical perspective because
if if the conversation is drawn away
from the actual game to talk about stuff
like that
yeah this game's a technical game so you
know
like it's going to be interesting to see
how it runs like i hope it runs good
like this game isn't really anything for
me but
i do understand that like we kind of
need more developers doing this horror
stuff
but we need more people doing it because
a lot of people do it and it's just to
me it's like they
they're a team that has shown they know
what to they know what they're doing in
terms of horror
so and this is their first chance to
shine in a way where there's
it's not necessarily a super small game
there aren't a lot of games around it
it obviously has the conversation around
that is the first next gen quote unquote
exclusive and stuff so
you know they have they have stuff to
live up to even if that's not what they
wanted or expected that
how people are going to be looking at it
yeah fair enough man like the king has
returned which is
hopefully get his head situation get the
super chat solve over that i'll jump in
if oh
jumping um okay we have hold on a second
we had to live in flames we got
oh no no i got lord roughness already
hold on
apologies the living flame two dollar
super chat the medium is 30 frames per
second across the board funds
okay yeah we don't do a reality a whole
bit yeah but you know what
it's i heard it's a i know a guy who's
playing it right now for a review
yeah and i don't know much about the
game he won't tell me
you know but uh the game itself though
uh
at 30 frames
look i heard it's a very demanding game
that's what he says
very demanding fair enough king the king
has returned
we missed you man you have no idea what
the hell's going on
they trying to silence the king boy
i was sitting there i was fighting i was
fighting boys this is your topic man so
you write it you write it pop pocket
as far as hitman 3 you know i know you
wanted to talk about performance you
touch briefly on that and maybe
about tools i think you want to hit that
so oh yeah yeah okay
so i told you guys what was going to
happen when microsoft
got a chance to get these uh gdk's up
and these sdks moving
mm-hmm and you know and i'm with fives
on the 60 frames per second
yeah and the medium is at 30 frames per
second but uh
doing dual worlds maybe they can do 60.
okay but um you know and they
they're using old gdk's and all sdks and
all the stuff that we don't make games
that we don't care about
you know we just care about 60 frames
per second because we have been
eating off of that plate and we like it
right bob
we like yeah yeah yeah you know one
thing that might help the game is the
fact that it's a fixed
camera angle yes yeah and and that might
help the 30 frames some because some of
these games where you can actually
control the camera and everything oh
that gives you a
headache man yeah so bad we're we're
at this point right now do do you lower
the resolution like the playstation
and uh okay here we go
hit that 60 frames per second because as
we've seen
with digital foundry actually exposing
these dudes at this 1880 whatever weird
number that they're at the shadows too
don't forget the shadows
yeah you know and then they got them
extra soft shadows you know
i think why they actually extra
so now now i had dudes but that's a
one-off king no
bro yeah this this is what's to come
this is this is this is what's on your
plate now
all right so this this is what you're
gonna be eating from now on you're gonna
be eating
a fist full of power um
shout out to microsoft and you know the
updated sdk
and stuff that i don't develop for i'm
worrying about his results
now before people were saying power
didn't matter when we had the 12
teraflops right
then you know but king the games are
outperforming them so now you care about
we see what it do so what you're gonna
say is but king that they're bored with
the flowers
okay remember digital foundry said if
they lowered the resolution like sony
did
then maybe they could hit that why don't
you ask sony to do what microsoft did
and do
4k for real why don't you do that why
don't you ask more for that same price
console
that you paid for that you're
championing about why don't you ask
them to do 4k and stop giving you this
weird 1880p
are you implying that if they tried to
do 4k the performance would
take well it's been implied by digital
foundry
4k that it would definitely be uh 30
frames per second
locked 30 frames per second you're back
at your mid-gen refresh you're looking
for the new
uh playstation 5 pro and i told you
dudes power was coming power's in the
building
i want to give a shout out to my man
dealer i want to guess because i watched
this vid
video and you know dylan has been doing
videos sparingly
so when they do come out there fine
dining and i sat down and i had my food
and i was eating and i was soaking it
all up because dealer could tell you it
in a manner that i don't understand it
but he makes it
you know for the layman so he explained
to me this is going to go on from now on
that's a dealer you own to something
this was one of those games that i said
you know what i might have to purchase
and i've noticed that microsoft has
secretly gone back with these companies
and they have fixed some of the games
that were outperforming them
on the inferior console that shall not
be named right now the cool
console y'all got a nice cooling device
over there so
i just want y'all to know this right you
tcl dudes are safe
you're safe why they say
safe you're safe but for all you guys
that you know actually
ask for more and demand for more and
want that 4k you want that real
4k experience 60 frames per second
microsoft has heard your cries
and just like that that the doubling up
on the games with gold
they're back and they're doing it again
for you baby
they're giving you that power that you
asked for and they give you that
performance that fonz
loves tcl
like checks our channel they're like yo
you know let's see if they change a
little bit
and then you you you do whatever you can
to make it worse
you know what here's the thing here's
where i differ a bit from you king
i would prefer them to lower that
resolution and them soft shadow give me
those soft shadows for 60 frames
i don't want salt shadows
i like my shadows with a little rough
tooth but i'm gonna tell you this king i
think
we're gonna get to the point when you
see the true next-gen stuff
that they are going to be dropping that
resolution they're going to be using vrs
they're going to be using machine
learning
the internal resolutions are going to be
lower you're going to see all this hot
ray tracing and you're going to see
hopefully the performance there
but actual resolutions are gonna be
lower than what we're saying now
okay so but it still will be higher than
sony
so all that you talk about
so why is this gotta be a measuring
what you said right there was here
they're going to lower the resolution
but not lower than sony's
oh [ __ ] kick superman look we'll get the
super chat then i can get my balls off
we got we got doobie hold on
with the two dollar super chat hitman is
four can actually 1800 p on ps5 yes
king is well aware of that very weird
um that's it we're good all right let me
get my balls look bad
i was in the same situation kind of um
some of the king in the sense that like
hitman games i like you know what i'm
saying and i had i remember picking up
the first or the second one i think they
were a game pass it was a great deal or
whatever it was
and for whatever reason i just i think
destiny was good at the time i think
that's been forsaken time
and you know ideas you pick up all the
games and destiny's good and i don't
play enough
but you know i ain't gonna front i had
no intentions of picking this joint up i
watched the digital foundry journey and
i ain't gonna front when lindemann was
talking and they did that dubai level
when he's scaling the outside of it uh
it is this like this monumental
skyscraper
in the cloud then you got all the arabs
all these
npcs in one spot and hitman's moving
around the reflections on the
i'm like god this game looked crazy i
was like yeah yeah
i got weak it looks really nice
i was like yeah i gotta break off this i
i gotta
be like yeah they'll be like you can
only go in here if you're security i'm
like what
what poor security guard ain't with
everyone else
[Music]
hey smitty smith with that five dollar
super chat says don't worry lord king
playstation has a 4k at-home screen got
the home screen oh come on
that's the only place nothing's moving
i've done it
that's when they can give you a static
4k yo what happened to 8k was on the box
why was 8k
on the box i never understood
and i am glad xbox didn't put that on
the box
cause you know why it's not real so why
would you put that on the box
you should you might as well put uh
flying dinosaurs too on the box
because you can't do that either so i
don't understand
you know you guys i i waited for this
topic
they tried to silence me and i got my
way back in here
usually i have cog helped me through all
technical problems i fought my way to
get back in here
i saw the topic and i said there's no
way you're not gonna
and then a little epiphany popped over
my head and said you on to something
i did one thing and i was back hold up
hold on
g from lord together.that said king that
8k
chip was everywhere on the on of the
summer with the 8k on the on the series
x chip
yeah but the thing with yours is it
don't work
the place yeah
unless you're doing something like pong
you can't do 8k
all right so listen let's stop that
right now you can't listen it's this
latest game
the game that everybody is raving about
hitman 3
the game with all the fun your
resolution is weak boy
your shadows are soft so that was a song
it was soft shadow i was so happy when
john lennon and the team found out y'all
had
soft shadows i just walked away from the
tv i had to go get me some ice cream
because i said this is the time the worm
has turned and it's on now
i can't wait we're on your hands
moving to my description of hitman that
i really enjoyed oh
yeah look at the end of the day it is
phenomenal looking i'm i'm all in
i'm definitely playing it and what i
like is like i said the other hitmans
are in so you can play the sequence all
the way for the prologue
yo shout out to the glacier engine soft
that glacier engine is really moving out
here and i like how it's adaptable and i
like how they
they brought up the other older games as
well so as far as kings point to the
tools i don't know you know what i'm
saying i don't know if they
i'm gonna i'm gonna defer the dealer i'm
gonna defer to you guys if the tools are
starting
to mature you know what i'm saying
because that is a cool thing and people
who bought a series x want to see these
power differentials that king
clearly launched so um yeah yes no no
it's not i clearly wanted they promised
me 12 teraflops
yeah i feel that you know and and these
other dudes is just 9 with the boost
mode
i want you to blast them i'm sorry
to me because i had to sit there i'm
beaten i'm beaten by them with that
power that they had when we started in
the beginning
different generations i didn't like this
this is this is the payback
it breaks over the garden okay i got i
got you i got this
okay and i i really respect
the engineers at microsoft you know i
respect them factual
but i want them i want their hard work
to shine
and it's shining right now i'm not you
know what today i'm gonna go by
um hitman three are you ready to support
the guys
because because it's putting the foot on
your neck i don't i don't want the foot
off i like the foot on your neck
so i'm i'm gonna buy hitman 3 and i'm
going to show my support for the dev
that
actually gave me what i was looking for
entertainment
you stupid put the crescent in the chat
for our brother apple cat we're just
joining the realm
salute put the crests up you know what
i'm saying so i'll get the super chats
we got smitty smith with the five
dollars sorry christopher
i don't speak tcl please beat me up here
in color because i only speak oh lad
thank you and you're welcome the ilp
more scripture book of acts
there we got hold up there we got soma
king
we got some king etc with the three
three
three pound with 41 pence
i had to put the exact number thank you
thank you 47 years old and only recently
regret being named craig
that was good that was good that was
very good that was good then we got
somebody smith again with the five
dollar super chat chris you cannot beat
me i am the bane of your existence
talk to me when you get your own emoji
oh he flexing
my 2015 sony bravia wouldn't turn on
this morning so
i'm now the owner of a lg nano cell hit
that like button for gamers voices being
heard
see you didn't go that route of picking
your tv up off the floor god bless
brother
welcome welcome oh we all cut up now
yeah all right cool so look man let's
move on
can i just say can i just say that that
they can't there's nobody that talks
like me
anywhere anywhere he can sell you
something that you didn't even know you
needed you're the best
i've been dealing with all my life like
he's almost got me convinced yes
of all this stuff he's talking about and
half of this stuff
is nonsense but i love it listen man
we're going up with this listen you know
there's something wrong
when you walk in the store and your tv's
on the floor looking at you
there's something wrong with that you
know it's you know what your experience
is you like to go inside best buy
you go and see the tvs on the wall you
talk to the guy
they go in the back they bring it to the
front and you leave
when you walk in and you're not sir when
i when i walk into those stores and i
buy a tv i go to that special room
the magnolia yeah yeah you go to the
magnolia room right
all those i walked past all those tv's
on the floor
you go to the tv and
and the guy comes over and he goes yes
sir yeah you know
yeah magnolia oh yeah so
i'm just trying to you know tell people
your tv shouldn't greet you when you
walk in that's
all and you shouldn't be able to pick it
up
got 108 coming for us both machines say
8k
they never said 8k gaming they said 8k
capable which refers to streaming
in terms of netflix and other app stop
defraudery
are you are you saying that click that
king selectively says certain things
not in the kitchen
for me yeah he talked about what else we
got we got eagles fan 76 five dollar
super chat
front alert to the console warlords we
have hit a new low captain for w's
on getting an exclusive demo not a full
game a demo
damn eagles fan are we really always
are we getting that argument with the
with the res evil demo the people
in the chat yeah people have checked
some of their seriousness they ride it
for this dead body like yeah because
they don't have nothing to play over
there ever since
finishing three hours they were stuck
but see listen
y'all got a horror game demo and we got
a horror game coming
um damn you know they got the same game
coming right
mm-hmm you know they got the same game
coming right which one would you talk
about
resident evil
resident evil what is going on man
there's a new one right
what's going on i got to say it the way
they would say
resident evil 8 or 9
whatever one we're on right now village
look uh i i've been
you know i've always been a huge fan of
resident evil
um i was actually one of those people
that started fresno before
but um i played one two and three after
they came back and i i'm not i'm i'm
still not a big fan of the first person
yeah view because i've always played
resident evil as a third-person game
i feel the same but it's growing on me
especially what i saw because
first off i want to you know go ahead
and stay laid out for the realm you know
obviously resident evil 8 was
shown a little bit more in terms of what
they played i think they over
exaggerated this event to be honest with
you i thought there was going to be more
and there wasn't but you know resident
evil 8
it's it's out there we're seeing more
game play on it we're seeing more
uh information on it kind of gives me
like a resident evil 4 vibe just in a
first person view
you know they got the uh the dude that
was there what you buy
i mean you know me and john were being
ran apart you just started saying that
for no reason
thank you they fight at a high price
you deserve i like how they brought you
someone that kind of mimic him and not
be exactly him
i would have liked him actually but you
know this dude looks cool i like the
direction they're going for resident
evil 8 i would prefer
it to be in third person but i've gotten
to the point resident evil 7 was ok
enough it was good enough for
i can i could trust them with this one
but i want to know your guys's opinion
to anyone here see it does someone not
see it
i don't have access to the demo because
i don't have a playstation and unlike
king i am going to say that was a good
look to get you know an exclusive demo
to a high
uh highly rated well not highly rated
highly hyped game that's coming out
later on this year
uh if you have access to this demo what
did you think about the demo and
uh you know i won't show up cognito
because i know he had it yeah i mean i
saw the event
and um i thought it was cool shout out
to the chat what's that lady
damn skill lady damascus looking crazy
out here you know saying so it's good to
see the community get behind
it look good did we see what chris is in
it you know what i'm saying so
you got that whole thing that chris flip
out like what's going on with chris
redfield so that's
the whole thing you know it's cool like
i'm with you like at first you know
i'm i grew up from the old resident evil
you know i'm saying barry where's barry
i'm from that that's me he doesn't so
but at the end of the day
i care for like with seven they proved
to me
that they could do first person and
scare the hell out yeah
you know so that that was impressive i
did
uh download i did play maiden on what's
going to demo the ps5
i will say from my understanding it is a
separate sub story
about this maiden in the joint i guess
she when you wake up she's trapped at
the bottom of this thing
and then someone sends you a note you're
trying to escape so they
someone is is bagging up maidens and
locking them in the bottom dungeons and
castles i don't know what's going on
but it had the vintage vibe it scared
the hell out of me
it is very the tension is very intense
shout out to the 4k
shot to the hdr i go this is a it was it
was 4k
i believe so i believe so yeah it is oh
wait let me see when did you found out
don't take my word for it no they
already they already broke it down they
said 4k six oh i thank you son for
defending because you
right there's nothing going on there's a
walk-in he's walking around yeah
i'm just saying because you know i did
i'm not down i'm not
booting up my system for a demo but what
i
what i would say is i saw it
um i'm very pleased that they went the
vampire route and i think i've always
wanted that uh type of thing because i'm
i'm really sick and tired of the t virus
you know and i guess to me like it just
it doesn't make sense it's like
how long is this this gone around how
long are these zombies i mean
at this point they're damn near in like
10 years into the in the woods
so we've not seen no vampires they when
i see no werewolves like
like to me that's where i see the
disconnect but as long as they do it
well and chris is in there i've always
been
but i think it's all still going to come
back down to some viruses you know the
tv
is going to make it fair but look well i
was talking to dreamcast guy and i was
like the good thing about it is they got
they got the umbrella corp so they could
just blame everything on like every time
the game
is getting mid they're like yo just say
the umbrella chord
are we gonna gloss over the fact that
everybody gets a switch version too
well with the multiplayer switch with
this with the switch game you ain't see
the the cell shaded
switch looking games
yeah all right so they have a
multiplayer because like re
reverse residence something like that
and
it is it sells is cell shaded and you
get a chance to play
i think it's four on four and with
various uh
characters from the resident evil
universe and
you know you had uh what uh that the guy
the
the father in the game you had nemesis
inside the game
you had claire inside the game you had
jill inside the game
and i'm like oh it's going to be fun but
it looks like something that's on switch
you know it looked like a switch game
but it looks like something fun and it's
free
everybody gets that free and yeah and
microsoft gets a demo
as well it's not maiden it's the a guy
that they said that's going to be in the
basement or something like that right
and they get that sometime later
yeah so let me just finish real quick
cause i i played made it so like i said
the thing about it that struck me like i
said they got the sense of fear they got
the sense of attention the game looks
phenomenal
some of the best like now where it got
me is once you start escaping the
dungeon and you start doing your typical
resident evil puzzles find this item to
do this and get this wrench to break
these chains and do like typical
resident evil stuff right
right as you start going through and
then you get into now
the this castle this estate right it
gave me
the resident evil one vibes like you
always in this illustrious kind of uh
you know the same place and the oh my
god the tapestry the fireplace
it looks phenomenal you as somebody some
rich person out
but i think they clearly do evil stuff
to people in there i think on the xbox
series x and the ps5 this is gonna be
one of the best looking games yeah this
game is a looker like you
show this thing off you know what i'm
saying and they got the sounds this is
the type of game that you're trying to
get like someone in the game he's like
yo look at this game
and this is despite it being cross-gen
because you're to get an xbox one
version you're going to get an
update forward right the sound of
cyberpunk
ways like i mean i mean come on that's
fearful stuff now you're talking some
fearful no but
i mean no no but the thing about it is
is different because obviously the re
engine they've already worked on those
past consoles like
the cyberpunk's engine was built from
the ground up and
apparently it was not optimized for
last-gen consoles
yeah all i was saying is look you know i
very promising waiting to see what the
the full jerk right is going to look
like and i'm gonna front side
addict this joint may be mad on kong now
you know how you can't play hellblade
and i can play hellblade destroy made me
uncomfortable so i said i don't know if
i would be
i'm gonna deep dive with this one son
you didn't play seven
i'm god he like because i it was making
me uncomfortable it's the first person
but i don't see myself and i gotta look
around like
what the hell was that and i think i
think that's what makes it
i i kind of i i don't agree with not
liking
ari that's not third person because i
know it's what we're used to right but
once they put it in first person i think
they got the scariness yes i agree
now i will give them this though they
did figure out the scary again in third
person with re2 remake because
when you're when when you aim at a
zombie
and your aim isn't perfect and you're
and they're fumbling towards you you're
like oh my god like if you turn off aim
assist
oh it's terrifying because you're like
wait he's fumbling towards me and
i may miss two shots so they figured it
out
i think the first person though i think
they hit a home run with that i really
yeah yeah shout out shout out to gene
for being messy come on cog resident
evil 7 and vr let's go hell
to the notes i'm not doing it i'm a
grown man i'm not
i literally tell anybody that is the
scariest
name on that playstation you know vr oh
shout out to
my playstation vr if you want my
playstation vr hit me up i got seven
games that can go with it it's out the
door
hit me in my dm
we got super chat and then yeah yeah we
got a couple guys errata mr two dollar
super chat
code veronica is the only re game in my
book oh they need to remember
that was a good one yeah first fully 3d
one yeah
uh jd gamer 10 super chat you know how
funny is going to be when xbox acquires
capcom after these fools have been
capping for a demo
just like they were capping for those
bethesda games when microsoft shows up
they buy the company hold up put the
trumpets up
my man for boy gaming gaming
that's the homie we will be the crew
bombing the crew husking the crew yo
salute the fourth way oh good dude
let me do that uh hot chip challenge
right yeah shut up
now look at the formula because i want
to shout them out because they do this
cool thing where they actually
game with the community man right there
they put extremists everyone together
i've got the name i'm off top because i
was in there
with season game and was playing halo
together but yo follow those dudes man
positive people in the community and
they play games together
and they they stream it so salute to
them let's get the rest of each out we
got the rubber knob with the five dollar
super chat
yeah morning lords
are stupid good morning lords gold price
increase got thrown into spiky bushes
ain't nobody looking look going in there
looking for that
yes then we got ramon terrell with the
five dollar super chat yes
shout out to farms bringing me to this
green this green podcast great i'm so
means great uh king got me messed up
shout out to ramon great guy that's
what's up absolutely no doubt great show
you guys are hilarious thank you wrong
oh much love
thanks for joining us checking out the
room we caught up yeah i think we're
caught up all right so franz thoughts
band
residents uh resident evil you know i
i'm a fraud i didn't even play seven
yeah partly because i it didn't give me
that third person perspective that i
that i wanted from resident evil but
also
because i'm just kind of chicken bro i
give it a book right it ends up with all
these grown men
not beautiful
it's a first person thing it really is
because i played
um the demo for that uh what was that
game that was on sony for a while it was
a demo for
pt pt yo that's a freak i'm with you bro
let me set that up so i played that demo
in the middle of the night
all the lights were off and just the
noises oh
[Music]
and things that were going on and then
the lady looks through the window and
i'm like whoa
i'm like okay i'm out hold up one second
for hardwood shout out by man italian
clowns four guys
welcome to the real this is a day one
homie
always supports gaming really doing this
thing man yo
salute to him man i hope he's feeling
better yeah hopefully he's feeling a
little better i was podcasting with him
about four guys recorders and he was
with me on grg
you know salute to that brother he
always does this thing always positive
in the community my man
italian clowns number one goomba new
york you already know toys r us stand up
all right
i just said that yeah those that first
person
perspective is just it really does add
so much more to it
and forget about even playing that in vr
no
way you know there's just no freaking
way
um yeah people are making fun you know
that some of us don't like those sort of
things
and i don't want to be jump scared every
few minutes no and enjoy a game
fun it is actually more people than i
would expect i do you know i'm just i i
it doesn't bother me i like i like
horror movies i like
uh stuff like that and i don't mind it
when i could see the character
you know because it does help because
you could see stuff going around you and
stuff
but what did you think of remake to to
remake
oh i i tried i dabbled with it here and
there uh i didn't play through the the
thing i played the demo a little bit
and it was it was okay it didn't really
scare me like those other games like uh
you know uh
re7 look i think pta shout out to my man
to my cali brothers we're about to do
this raid as soon as i get out of here
yeah
that's a really good idea i played i
played resident evil 2 years ago
man like so i i know it's a little bit
different and everything
you know what it is i obviously the the
older games they purposely like
obviously the tank controls were there
for a reason right it was yeah
it was to make you feel kind of helpless
right and for you to get out of a
situation
there was a whole thing you needed to
learn how to do to get out of situations
uh
shout out to lord ha for being like a
master master with that fact
that's where the terror came from right
with something stumbling towards you
that you're not necessarily faster than
and it's
and i mean i commend them for remake
because remake
to me got it right in a different way
and this to me gets it right in a
different way i know a lot of people
when it's funny because i love four but
four was sort of the harbinger of things
to come when in terms of the action
right and then five sort of took it
straight up action six was something
else entirely
yeah i i definitely don't hate on the re
series
i mean more power to you you you do you
you play those games
awesome but yeah i'm going to do my own
thing
uh but yeah he's like
i love this series back in the day when
it was third person absolutely not
afraid
i feel that man let's get uh any super
chance to get king and it was wrong
hold on a second we have
uh six slayer with the five dollar super
chat great show
thus far guys actually holding me up
from finishing up work and going home
salute to sick man good dude man
definitely grg podcast i
want to wait that's my guy yeah we good
all right cool
um king did you are you interested in
the uh of course
okay i've purchased seven on uh
two platforms now and was happy when it
got launched in game pass
you know i think that was probably one
of the strolls that broke the game well
camelback and game pass
uh because i when when it came to cam
game pass i brought the season pass
for it and that game
like it and and i played it from the
beginning and it got me again
the same thing like you hear me
literally screaming man my daughter was
sitting there laughing to death
because i'm literally screaming when the
girl comes out and she she cuts your
hand off
and you know things happen it is so
terrifying like i'm in a hole and i'm
crawling and i'm looking behind me
making sure nobody's coming behind me
and i'm crawling and i'm crawling and i
look again
and i see her coming behind me and i'm
trying to crawl faster but then the
light is going out
it is the most horrifying terrifying
game and i guess it's because
of the first person view and they
finally nailed it like you guys were
saying
i like when you when you there's a part
where you got to hide in the crack in
the wall
[Music]
which lady is going from roona where are
you
oh hell no hell no i'm gonna get you
no wall when you clock when you climb
under that like part of the porch and
she
she grabs your feet and yates you out
yes
yo it is it is okay
the reason why it scared the hell out of
me
the hillbilly aspect of it
they they pick see i gotta give capcom
the diversity shout out yeah because
they went with the mexicans mm-hmm
you know like they're like you know
whatever they were they were they were
in
so but then they went to africa and so
and they had the african zombies
because they did they did the caucasian
zombies first and then you know they did
the
urban zones they had the
african-americans then they did the
mexican zombies spain
spain
the hell out of me because i don't care
what anybody say when you're on a road
and let's say you're going through
alabama wherever
you get your flat tire and it's late at
night you're like man oh man
at that point at that point you're
sitting in your car and you're like it's
over i'm done
like howdy partner do you need any help
with that
yeah is that texas chainsaw
massachusetts
yes follow me over to my house i got a
jack i can jack it up over there on the
hitch and we get you all right there
good you want something to eat here
buddy
i don't like how you're being so
accurate
feeling with attic you're feeling
so now i'm seeing eight and i've always
wanted like that vampire
i was really happy when i saw the the
the sisters
swirling around and i don't know if
those are moths of bats
flying around them but it looks great
and then i seen
the the like the head mistress with the
hat on and
yeah apparently that's the the hillbilly
sister
i want to know the story i i think
resident evil has a rich law
a beautiful story and now that we have
these uh
next-gen consoles that's able to push
out this fidelity no matter what the
resolution is
um on uh you know soft shadows
oh man i can't wait to get a chance you
know to play this
and i'm so happy right now that they're
pushing us 60 frames per second there
yeah you know facts fast you can have
that story by the way
good to see you you're not going to jump
in files with the 60s
i'm good man i'll watch you play it
though
i'll watch you oh you know what live
stream that i'm gonna live stream now oh
man we got clowns
yeah yeah yeah i know i know that that's
gonna be fun to watch
um we got clowns with the five dollar
super chat phil dominus maximus aurelius
spencer is pro
humor and threw thor's hammer down and
said reverse the increase in gold
i'm not quite sure that's how it
happened we'll go with it
clowns
any way to get a patreon tier for lord
[ __ ] to stream him playing re7
i think i think it's time to update our
tears
after i took this one chip challenge
fine let's go with tattoo
i think i think you we need patreons to
say what they would like to see the
lords do and what tiers do we need to
have
some new some new tears for lord king
i want you guys in the chat to put to
put a cheer you would like to see from
every
lord keep in mind i i would deny these
if they're too much
we have shooting kingdom with the two
dollars which basically capcom said
every race can get it right it's real i
love that diversity
equal opportunity
hopefully i don't know about that tier
it will continue to move up anyway
so we got 10 cent out here y'all 10 cent
man
acquisition talks man i want to shout
out a couple of people real quick
shout out the lord z huge and i believe
round hill
investments and um yeah they were just
talking about how they're looking to
acquire a larger gaming company
currently raising several billion
dollars and then they talked about
you know basically 10 cent considering
debt financing for a possible gaming
deal
they're looking at a possible
acquisition of a gaming business
according to tmt finance
and the target has not been identified
yet but it's expected to be a gaming
company in the us
or south korea so 10 cent is out here
looming and then basically there's
another article i believe pc gamer how
they kind of talked about how
how many hands saw like they have their
you know their fingers
you know tentacles everywhere yeah man
so you know any
like have investments i believe with
ubisoft activision blizzard and epic
and man it's very very surprising when
you see
what they are in you know digital
extremes that make us a warframe they
own splash damage with code
they've invested in so many kinds of
everything
and they just purchased the majority
sharing clay entertainment play
entertainment
had published agreement with amazon
chinese release of a lord of the rings
mmo
they got subsidiary athlon games their
shareholder
i mean they are they definitely have
their hands on a lot of things so i just
wanted to bring it
around it's it's pretty you know they
comment i don't know if these are the
white walkers that king talked about
but um 10 cents out here how do you feel
my question to you guys is how do you
feel about their presence
and does this affect the big three in
terms of maybe
giving more urgency for them to lock
down big dab studios now that the sharks
in the water
big ten cent out here is lurking let's
be real here it's not the big three it's
microsoft and the other two might buy
something
in nintendo's defense they just locked
down many people were surprised but we
had
last two iops next level games which was
already had a great relationship so we
were surprised why they felt the need
for them to lock down so do you think
nintendo felt a little bit i just feel
like
in terms of what you're talking about
spending billions of dollars on
something it's going to be
something relevant okay and i don't
think nintendo's sort of
in that conversation
let's just be real here do you think
sony and nintendo will be dropping a
couple billion dollars on something
so yeah no no but i think i think beyond
the the
they might buy the plumbing points yeah
no i'm saying but but even then i mean
again they purchased clay entertainment
and there's more than one game there
right but i think they're looking at
small and large purchases so
there's there's there's gaming centric
obviously devs and stuff like that
that i would not necessarily like
tencent to have
per se so like again i would prefer
nintendo
playstation microsoft by all the studios
before tencent buys one
yeah i i agree 100 and so them looking
at a publisher as well
yeah yeah that's a little scary man i
just don't like the practices over at
tencent i don't like the
racism and sovereignty i don't like uh
how they tried to culturally divide
certain things over at 10 cent
i don't like a lot of things that i've
been hearing
uh and i and i don't know firsthand
because i don't work for 10 cent
but what i'm saying is i don't like the
narrative that is behind tencent and
the way that they're moving in the
background so nefariously
i believe that it will uh come to a
point where it's detrimental to
our industry um if they start to get
games
and companies and start to monetize them
in a way that
most of your favorite games turns into
cell phone games
because i think a company that big with
that much
uh nefarious reach in the background
that has been able to move in the
background so
silently from how big they are i mean
we've been talking about tennis and felt
like you look
yeah if you look at it from a standpoint
on what tinson's doing
tencent has been so dominant and extra
when it comes to their purchasing and
how they're handling the industry
that the united states is like yo should
we look at this
yes yeah there's a lot of negativity
surrounding tencent for sure but the
biggest
thing for me it comes down to their
whole
you know uh business structure relies
heavily around micro
transactions yeah this is where they
make the bulk
of their profits and that scares the
hell out of me because i do not want
them
purchasing say a big publisher and
making it all about
micro transactions i mean let's be real
here though like how many that's what
would happen
how many of these big publishers already
don't microtransaction us today oh true
oh no that's not true i i think that
they could they they could actually make
some of these games
that we maybe you know didn't have
microtransactions with them in them
previously
now they're just full of them and and
i'm talking single-player games
yeah like resident evil yeah i think i
think
what you one of the biggest things you
got to look at with them is
sort of their eye on cloud computing and
and where they plan to go with that i
think uh
in terms of i guess worldwide lockdown
has
sort of caused them to focus a lot more
on the technical aspects of that as
opposed to i know that you were talking
about the game stuff and they're
definitely continuing to look at the
game stuff
but i think the change in sort of that
the dynamics of the world has sort of
have made them shift their focus more to
be like king was saying behind the
scenes so you know you're looking at
you know cloud stuff with google with
amazon with microsoft
um these are guys that have fu money
just like they do
yeah see i think the difference is
though is like
microsoft wouldn't do the stuff they do
like like tinsel will go up and drop 10
billion dollars and not blink twice
like they don't care like yeah it feels
it feels like they it feels like they're
less considerate of it than
right it almost says perfect thing
slow-mo in the chat says
what if they uh due to recent issues
they go out and purchase a company like
cd projekt red and that's a company that
has long stood against
you know uh just downright you know
scandalous microtransactions and if they
were to buy them
better believe they're going to be here
and then let me ask you a question right
i'm thinking about it this way
because the way i've seen uh tents and
how they do it they buy
patches of stock right and they
and they keep buying patches of stock
and then they they go to individual
shareholders who have a larger stake in
the stock
until they get to the point where
they're close to like uh 38
of the stock shares and then they go to
individual stockholders that have larger
purchases of the pie
and buy them out from their shares right
because you can transfer stock shares
over to a separate entity after you know
they purchased them out
they sell them directly to tencent
tencent becomes the majority holder
and then that's when they take a
corporate takeover of the company
it's not like they're going in there and
actually bidding on said company
they're going in and they're purchasing
stock at a low value
when they get to a certain number then
they reach over
my question to you um fonz
do you believe because that's a
nefarious practice right oh of course
a corporate takeover right and you said
cd projekt red
cd projekt red i don't know if they are
on open market yet are they on open
market are still private because i
believe they have private
they're private but but you know money
talks
and uh they've got the money right and
because of the recent issues and stuff
surrounding cd projekt red who knows if
they would be more apt to
you know go public you know who knows um
but you've got other companies like
ubisoft you know yes they could just
go through they've already got shares in
ubisoft so that they can definitely take
over there
that's my it's one of those things it's
like everybody you may not be for sale
but everybody has a price
that's that's what it's not like the
billionaire
corporations guard against hostile
takeovers
by uh diversifying the shares and you
know splitting shares and stuff like
that right
not to go into the whole market thing
but
once one company sets their eyes on
purchasing enough shares
that they can get in position that they
can isolate those who have higher shares
they can actually do a corporate
takeover and
this is that's my fear with them right
because when you start to look at their
portfolio
they have hands in everybody
and look at how they came to ubisoft's
uh sort of rescue
they stepped in when vivendi was trying
to definitely
do a hostile takeover and they came and
be like now we'll help you
we'll help you edit and it's you know
and it's that i remember
what's the quote from uh from hannibal
or something like that it's like when
the fox hears the something
when the fox hears the rabbit cry he
comes running
but not to help yeah and they're
essentially grooming
these companies yes you know it's it's
scandalous
and and it could very well happen to any
of these companies that they've already
got a sharing
and uh some of them more than others but
they've got shares in
every everything and everything it's
yeah it's it's
we've been saying this for like two
years and i was like
they they just keep and then there's
nobody telling them no
right there's nobody trying to fight
against this um
because you got money people wanted
everything listen money talks and not to
get political or anything like that
right but then
you know the political sort of
ramifications of this as well is that
well
you know some people believe that it's
you know the sort of quote-unquote sort
of
you know communist thinkings or whatever
trying to make their way into
into into u.s owned sort of uh companies
and stuff like that
there's a lot of arguments surrounding
you know kind of the quote-unquote blood
money
that u.s companies give to to chinese
companies
that sort of engage in the practices
that king was talking about before
so that's another sort of that's another
sort of barrier that they've been able
to sort of wiggle around
and they found the loophole that and and
how our business is structured
yeah and it's very it's very simple and
not
not to get on a whole big sorry but when
we say
everybody in the game industry believes
that this is only
big three microsoft nintendo and sony
right and you guys like if microsoft
doesn't buy him
buy them or or nintendo buy them and
then you'll say whoa
here's google oh here's amazon all right
and
those are the guys that y'all see in the
front and
you don't see this dude that's in the
background that's from a foreign country
that has different practices and
different beliefs and like fonz says
their whole business model is based on
uh loot crates and
uh micro transactions and how to
milk dry you right and just owning a
little bit of everything like
it's craziness the the crazy thing is
the average gamer or whatever doesn't
know who tencent is
tencent tencent is the
has makes the most revenue in gaming
yeah think about it think about it look
at this
riot games 100 percent ownership epic
epic games
40 percent blue oh 11 ubisoft 5
active vision blizzard five percent back
grinding gear games the path of exile
like
they just got an undisclosed investment
in platinum games super saiyan i mean
paradise these are huge like these are
little think about it this way you just
said
score last year including an un
undisclosed amount from 10 cent yeah
like
like i told you man they don't care like
you said when it comes to companies like
microsoft like
they do stuff if it makes sense like
they want their hands and everything
right
this is this is how you control 40
in epic think about it
40 in epic you have to find out where
those other shares are right
where are those other shares who would
tip the balance to get them to 51
because it's the thing is it's like is
tim sweeney going to sell out
like bullying crazy because it'll be
over there in fact
because that's when they will have a
severe monopoly on the industry
because that that middleware that
middleware
unreal engine 5 middleware
basically is going to be pushing the
generations forward
right so if it's the default the default
engine going forward for the majority of
the individuals
and one company holds control over
that and that company also has other
companies that they control it over
the dominance will be ridiculous yeah
yeah i just wanted to bring to attention
it's an interesting topic and around
crazy topics a lot of people aren't
talking about them i'm glad you guys
killed it man let's get this super chess
get up out of here
we'll go on a second i'm sorry i was
busy looking up tents and stuff
every time we bring up tencent it's the
same thing they bought this they bought
that
it's crazy what they are they have their
hands yeah so the only thing we have is
somebody submitted five dollars super
chat tension out here like the shadow
broker from massachusetts
that was good shout out
let's get this poll and get up out of
here man so
look we got nua people this week
with microsoft's quick reversal
on their recent xbox live gold price
increase and stance
on free-to-play games do you think it's
wrong to now shower praise on microsoft
for correcting this mistake
the judges are a yes stop praising them
microsoft should have never made this
mistake to begin with
sheep b no
outspoken gamers won companies rarely
reverse course
that quickly and they added free to play
see
i don't care where y'all going to rally
against them 70 games though
all the people right there this is sad
that that might be the only poll to ever
win the
the better kid listen man shout out to
everybody
yo shout out to lord fonzarelli the
grounded gay it's been a minute brother
i'm glad you said
man it's been working a lot so i know
his schedule's been rough but i know
when i always send out the bad signal to
you you always tried it was good to get
you i tried brother
i love coming to the uh to the lord's
house and being with you guys
uh it's it's awesome you're like a
second family to me here
in in the community um you know rdx and
my brothers
you guys are too and every time i can
get here
i i'm going to be here you know i love
the passion love what you represent
in the community on twitter you always
speak your mind and
good friend to the realm man you've
always from day one funds has always
been that little sage advice in my ear
you know saying always giving out good
advice man salute to you brother i
always
appreciate you when you appreciate it
yeah yeah no my man shout out to rdx the
whole team you already know what it is
you know what i'm saying so uh lord
attic man
what you got going on what's popping you
can follow me on twitter at lower
addicts iop
you can find me at uh i've been
streaming here a little bit more on
gaming
you can find me streaming over there i'm
gonna do a little couple opinion
videos next week because there's no news
going on so
i gotta i do i like opinion videos they
just take a lot longer
so you know it because i don't have like
a source to go off of like i have to do
everything
but uh i appreciate everyone coming
through with like 450 people at one
point you know
well it's definitely nice to see growth
uh i dropped some
codes in the chat probably gonna do uh
like some trivia next week for the
members and patreons but
i appreciate everyone for coming through
we'll be back next week we got some
surprise guests in the future
uh look forward to sharing more on that
and uh until next time
yes you already know lord solved man we
didn't get to see his face but he still
came through so we love it
yes sir yes sir uh hopefully you may not
see my face next week either
we'll see we'll see what happens but
yeah you can find me on twitter what's
up iop
retweeting everything under the sun so
that's that's what i do and that's what
i do best
and hopefully i i hopefully maybe be
able to get some hitman under my belt
this week uh
that's your channel
oh my god merc and murdoch
yeah that's that's my thing so and then
hopefully i'll have some things to say
about the medium next week
absolutely no doubt lord king
with all the smoke and corporate king
made a triumph return for a brief
segment
versus fonz first of all i would like to
give a shout out to fine i did i wasn't
gonna take that take on it
until spawn showed up so when
fine showed up i knew he was gonna have
a grounded perspective i knew he was
gonna have an even kill perspective on
it
i had to just lob bombs at home
on the opposite end of it because i knew
one he could take the joke
two he knew i wasn't serious three he
was going to defend his position by any
means
[Laughter]
i would like to give a shout out to
everybody that supports us thank you so
much uh to see so many people
on a sunday when it's football season
heating up and you guys are hanging out
with us you know with the jokes and the
fun
um also i'd like to give a shout out to
everybody that watched the last word
with a little cognito and ibantas
if you don't support destiny it's more
fun and jokes in there
even if you don't know what's going on
but they give you some education
also the guys that supported me on dolph
castlex oh yeah it's at 9pm if you don't
have nothing to do and you want to hear
a bunch of guys talk money and
comic books and facts and fun stuff and
you know
where did the king spend six thousand
dollars
um you know come check us out he did
spend six thousand dollars this week
yeah
and uh and on saturdays with my live
unboxings
like i said i'm changing my whole
collection over i'm going away from
sideshow
and i'm moving into the king of xm so as
my journey continues
uh live unboxings every saturday so you
get a chance to see
a thousand dollar statues being popped
up this weekend i made a huge purchase
um i've been tracking this statue down
so it'll be shipped out this week and uh
that
unboxing i want the community to stand
up because i spend six thousand dollars
i want you there to see my bg exactly
what i purchased
and what it's about and what what are
real statues and we'll give you
education along the way but thank you
guys for supporting us
for being here thank you fonzarelli for
coming through and
and hey having fun we didn't get any
chance to talk about conor mcgregor man
yeah uh you know what uh somebody asked
me who was gonna win that fight and i
said you know i can't pick who's going
to win the fight because they're both
great with their hands
but i will tell you somebody's getting
knocked out mm-hmm that's what happened
yeah man maybe they have money from
floyd he ain't basically oh poorie
pourier just fought a great fight man
those those calf kicks
perfect
he was soft he was softening the legs
but
i i felt that one he was weight drained
i saw it in his face
he's older yeah he hasn't had a chance
to mix it up
and he gave it up to him he said you
know the leg kicks was great
i have to stay active i i think this mma
stuff
affects these athletes with the cove it
affects these athletes
more than boxes boxers are used to being
off
uh four to five months and then coming
back
mma guys are doing a three to four month
turnaround
they're staying training and they're
staying fighting and they stand active
and they got to stay sharp
it's kind of sharp yeah yeah hey i like
conor's
new attitude though yeah yeah
yeah humble the last thing i said just
oh now i know we doing fight talking
but i i do believe when you make that
kind of bread that he's made
it does change you it is the motivation
there is the commitment there when you
make that
that mma guys don't make that type of
money he made with floyd
so that could change you now that's the
question is he gonna dig deep is he
going to stay around
because he's technically set you know
what i'm saying he got a proper twelve
yeah he'll be around
yeah probably proper to proper twitter
probably change the way you look at life
show i get farts in the building yo
thanks for the real everybody coming out
was a lot of fun
hopefully we may have a big surprise
coming up this sunday i don't want to
jinx it but stay tuned
and like alex said we got some crazy
guests and other stuff popping up but we
appreciate your support yo everybody
enjoy yourself
real quick i gotta say i i gotta say uh
i can't wait for king's unveiling of his
10
cent logo status oh yeah shout out you
listen uh i
i think i speak for all of us when the
iron lords are open to being purchased
by 10 cent if tencent drops the bag off
if anybody says no we will override them
listen
i would go to fill dominus maximus
really expensive myself and play the
radio outside his window like nah man
let this happen like people just say
anything
you know what song i think you're honest
i don't know i don't know if phil's
matching it man i don't know phil phil
got me
don't let them do me like this
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you